Almost heaven, older Twitch chat, all these emotes, wondering how to spell that.
Now we're older, everyone's moved on, but I remember Twitch chat from those days that are gone.
Twitch emotes, from long ago, made you feel you're not alone.
KappaPogChamp, keep a forehead, BibleThumb, Twitch emotes.
I remember typing Dan's game, forehead SwiftRage, PJ Salt and Failfish.
Life was easy, spamming all the time, TOS was nowhere, so everyone's feeling fine.
Twitch emotes, from long ago, made you feel you're not alone.
KappaPogChamp, keep a forehead, BibleThumb, Twitch emotes.
Still hear his bark in the morning hour, he calls me, his doggy emote reminds me of a time far away.
Looking at a chat, I get a feeling that I miss emotes from yesterday, yesterday.
Twitch emotes, from long ago, made you feel you're not alone.
Pog is PogChamp, Kappa is Kappa, BibleThumb, Twitch emotes.
KappaPogChamp, keep a forehead, BibleThumb, Twitch emotes.
Nasana, PC Lustig, das Ratchet, und der Hienopad subscribt, excellent.
Oh, bisschen groß vielleicht, das E-Mote, minimal zu groß.
Für neun Monate, huge IQ, boost.
Jelly ist auch am Start.
Und was empfiehlt uns, ich hab' schon ein paar Videos, oh hier, die Lego Burger Factory, die müssen wir uns gleich angucken, aber mal gucken was uns YouTube empfiehlt, ich hab' jetzt gar nicht geguckt, was uns YouTube empfiehlt. Jetzt müssen wir erstmal ne Runde Musik anmachen, was nehmen wir da hier irgendwie.
Keine Ahnung, irgendwas, vollkommen egal.
Die gucken eh hauptsächlich irgendwelche Videos, da ist Musik jetzt nicht so.
Hallo?
Okay.
Ähm...
Battlefield 4, Battlefield 4 Video haben wir schon.
C++ 20, MonkaS.
Ach nee, das ist ein Tutorial für Unreal, nee, oder für was auch immer.
Nee, für irgendwas selbst gebastelt.
Also okay, zum Glück kein C++ Tutorial.
Das hätt ich nämlich gleich hier, hätt ich gleich sagen müssen.
Not, not interested.
Oh, Making Indie Games Changed My Life.
Emo, es gibt keine Emos mehr, die sind alle weg.
Kennst du Minish Cap, ja? Klar, kenn ich.
Hab ich sogar gespielt.
Sogar bis, bis zum Schluss, also durchgespielt.
Magi im Check.
Warum YouTube, warum empfiehlst du mir Magi?
Ich weiß nicht, warum sich YouTube jetzt gedacht hat, Magi im Check, das musst du angucken.
Ich glaube, das ist so ein YouTube-Algorithmus-Ding, dass sie ein sieben Jahre altes Video mal wieder promoten.
Das müssen wir nachgucken.
Ja, vor neun Stunden.
Das wird grad wieder empfohlen.
Developer reagiert auf Speedrun Half Life 2.
Haben wir das nicht schon geguckt? Und war das nicht ein bisschen Resident Sleeper?
War das nicht ziemlich Resident Sleeper? Oh, das ist viel zu lang.
Das war ziemlich Resident Sleeper, fand ich.
Ich mein, wir haben schon Half Life 2 Speedrun geguckt, Half Life Speedrun.
Das ist halt zum größten Teil Out of Web geklitscht, gerade Half Life 2.
Das fand ich nicht so spannend.
Max, wir wollen doch heute ein 15-Minuten-Video anschauen,
hast du gestern gesagt. Echt? Welches denn?
Selfmade Ice, abonniert Twitch Prime.
Bisschen laut hier auf einmal die Musik, ne?
Können sich wieder nicht entscheiden.
Ja, Selfmade Ice, danke schön für den Sub. Exzellent.
Welches Video wollten wir uns... Ach, ich weiß wieder.
Ja, ich hab letztens... Ich weiß nicht, ob das heute so gut passt,
weil das ist jetzt ja halt nix unbedingt so zum Aufwachen.
Ich hab ja gestern mich ein bisschen zu ausgelassen,
dass wir in Deutschland so viel Geld haben oder auch nicht, ja.
Da hab ich gesagt, ich hab letztens ein ziemlich gutes,
vor ungefähr ca. 15 Minuten langes Video zu dem Thema gesehen.
Das können wir uns angucken. Das ist echt, finde ich, nicht schlecht gemacht,
aber ich weiß nicht, ob das...
...Aufwachmaterial ist.
Das war das hier, warte mal. Ich muss mal kurz in meine Playlist gucken,
dass ich das finde.
Das war eigentlich ganz gut.
Ziemlich neutral, ja.
Er hat einfach nur gesagt, wie es ist, und das fand ich gut.
Gibt's wenig, gibt's wenig, die das machen.
Ja.
Wo ist der Wohlstand für alle geblieben?
Wo ist das? Wie ist das?
Ja, das da.
Das fand ich war ein echt gutes Video.
Der hat's auf den Punkt gebracht. Relativ neutral, ja.
Ohne irgendwie rumzuflamen, ohne auch irgendwie groß angreifbar zu sein,
weil das ist ja...
Gerade in Deutschland ist es relativ einfach, wenn du ein falsches Wort sagst,
bist du gleich mal mindestens Nazi, wenn nicht Schlimmeres, ja.
Oder zumindest bist du irgendwie ganz, ganz schlimm und extrem,
nur weil irgendwas ein bisschen abseits gesagt hast von dem, was akzeptiert ist.
Und das Umschiff, der geschickt, der sagt einfach, wie es ist,
das finde ich eigentlich gerade eigentlich ganz gut gemacht haben.
So.
Was haben wir denn sonst noch für einen Witz?
Lego Burger, please, ja, das gucken wir gleich. Lego Burger ist das Beste.
Gibt es ein Video von dir zur PS5-Hardware und oder Unreal 5, ja?
Haben wir uns beide schon angeguckt?
Aber ich muss jetzt erst mal zum Aufwachen.
Muss ich, gibt nix, gibt nix, wir müssen uns die Burger Factory angucken.
Excellent, excellent.
Kennst du Game Brain auf YouTube?
Nee, oder vielleicht schon, aber der neue Channel sagt mir nichts.
Guck mal, sogar mit Tablet-Steuerung. Alter, hä?
Ich weiß nicht, ob man den Burger wirklich essen will.
Das war fraglich, aber die Technik ist geil.
Hast du das mit der VM und Mac OS hinbekommen?
Ja.
Ja, lief ganz gut, nachdem wir die VM-Tools installiert haben in VirtualBox.
Eigentlich merkwürdig, ne, aber es hat ganz okay funktioniert,
aber es war immer noch zu lahm, es ordentlich zu benutzen.
Hat nicht so ganz funktioniert.
Wie er das hier anliefert, hä? Guck mal hier, wie er das reinfährt.
Ich frag mich bei diesen Maschinen, wir haben jetzt ja schon ein paar Videos geguckt in der Richtung,
funktionieren die nur jetzt einmal fürs Video, weil er die exakt richtig auf den Millimeter positioniert hat,
oder funktioniert das immer.
Da, da, da ist eine Mücke, ich hab's genau gesehen.
Was ist denn das? Ach, das ist Ketchup und Senf, oder? Ja.
Was eine Sauerei, stellt euch mal vor, ihr müsst die Teile danach sauber machen.
Hat nicht so ganz funktioniert.
Was jetzt? Was war denn das jetzt?
Ah, das ist da, wo die Brötchen draufliegen, das wirft er weg.
Jetzt kommt der nächste. Oh, oh, das fällt runter.
Dann noch besser in Factorio, oder?
Ich glaube, in Factorio kann man keine Burger bauen.
Na ja. So, jetzt wird erstmal eine Runde Ketchup draufgesprayt, ach ne, doppelten, doppelten Belach.
Es ist cool, dass es funktioniert.
Sinnvoll ist es nicht, aber es ist cool, dass es funktioniert.
Na ja, oh, die Sauerei.
Als nächstes kommt dann die Burger Eating Factory. Genau, glaubt ihr irgendwas, was es ist?
Als nächstes Burger Eating Factory, danach kommt die Burger Cleaning Factory.
Und dann die Burger Refill Factory.
Aber es ist schon cool, wie er das gebaut hat.
Es ist schon nice, es ist schon nice. Es ist zwar komplett sinnlos, aber es ist nice.
TH Assassin sagt, der Burger sieht wie so ein Plastikburger aus für Commercials.
Na ja, eigentlich ja nicht, weil in der Werbung sehen die Burger immer besser aus als im Laden.
Ich habe es schon im Stream ein paar Mal erzählt, aber für die, die es noch nicht gehört haben, wusstet ihr,
dass McDonalds sogar eine richtige Five-Hat-Erklärung dafür hat, warum der Burger in der Werbung besser aussieht als im Laden.
Da sind die tatsächlich drauf eingegangen bei einer Frage.
Und McDonalds sagt, der Burger im Laden sieht anders aus als in der Werbung,
weil in der Werbung ist es darauf optimiert, dass der Kunde, oder auf den Vorschaubildern,
dass der Kunde erkennt und dass gut präsentiert wird, was alles im Burger drin ist.
Und wenn du es im Laden kaufst, ist der Burger Geschmack optimiert.
Deswegen sieht das anders aus. Also die haben sich dazu geäußert.
Ey der Typ, wie viele Lego Factories hat der eigentlich noch gebaut?
Zurück durch den Bagger, äh nicht den Bagger, wie komme ich auf Bagger, äh den Traktor.
Ich frage mich, wie lange der braucht für so eine Factory. Das ist nicht in einem Nachmittag erledigt.
Die Erfahrung macht es natürlich auch aus. Ich meine, wenn er irgendwelche Getriebe und Sachen, die was befördern, baut,
das ist grundsätzlich wahrscheinlich alles immer gleich.
Aber da bist du schon eine ganze Weile dran beschäftigt, bis du sowas fertig hast.
Exakt Easy Light, so sieht es aus.
Kommt jetzt, das ist ein Fließband, oder? So ein Beförderungsband.
Highly advanced.
Ja, das Search, das habe ich auch schon gelesen.
Das teilweise sogar, wenn es Toppings gibt, also in der Werbung, wenn die irgendwie Werbung machen zu einer Suppe oder so,
da gibt es irgendwelche Toppings, dass die dann auch mal mit Haarspray fixiert werden und sowas.
Das ist ja geil. Guck mal den Wasseranmacher.
Das ist Big Brain.
Das ist nice, das gefällt mir. Wirklich gut gewaschen wären die Dinger nicht.
Aber es wird sogar trocken gepustet.
Das ist ja, okay, okay, das ist wirklich Massive Brain, das Ding.
Das Trockenpusten ist ja mal richtig next level.
Ich bin gespannt, wie er das Ganze schneidet. Wenn er das schneidet, gibt es halt eine Riesensauerei, was die Legoteile auf Dauer nicht mitmachen.
Ich glaube, Legoteile und Fruchtsäure auf Dauer verträgt sich nicht.
Was ist das denn jetzt?
Okay, ich vermute mal, das drückt jetzt da oben drauf und hier schneidet es durch.
Dann geht das doch, da sind nämlich keine Legoteile hier, das ist irgendwas anderes mit Messern dran.
Ich finde, ich weiß nicht, ob es nur mir so geht, ich finde irgendwie diese Kameraeinstellung, irgendwie sieht die schmerzhaft aus.
Ich weiß auch nicht genau warum.
Es ist so, als könnte man spüren, dass der Apfel zerschnitten wird gerade.
Au.
Ich habe keinen Apfelschneider, so advancede Küchenutensilien habe ich nicht.
Wenn ich Äpfel esse, was nicht so oft vorkommt, weil Äpfel, lull, dann stein ich die mit dem Messer.
Ich weiß, das ist sehr low brain, aber es ist nicht so advanced wie das hier auf jeden Fall.
Die schneidet gar nicht, ja das geht auch.
Aber nachdem ich nicht gerne Äpfel esse, dann...
Nee, Apfel einfach abbeißen finde ich eklig.
Ohne, dass ich euch jetzt erklären kann warum, aber das mag ich nicht.
Da hängt dann so viel Spucke dran und so noch, weil man da reingebissen hat.
Mein alter Chef hat immer sein Apfel komplett gefuddert, so in gefühlt vier Bissen, inklusive Kerne, alles.
Der war da auf dem Schreibtisch und nach 30 Sekunden war er komplett weg.
Und das hat er gemacht wie das Normalste von der Welt.
Ich stand da manchmal so daneben und guck ihn so komisch an.
Und er meint so, was denn?
Jetzt wird erstmal noch die Birne zerhäckselt.
Oh, die ist schepp, die ist schepp, das wird nichts.
Ah, er hat gecheatet, habt ihr das gesehen?
Hier, Hex, guckt euch an, die Birne ist schepp.
Und jetzt, hier ist die Birne schepp und jetzt die Birne krat.
Da hat er nochmal eine extra Kamera, jetzt wird es aber hier übertrieben.
Okay.
Ist das eine Zitrone?
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich unbedingt so eine Zitrone haben will auf meine komplette Zitrone.
Ist vielleicht ein bisschen Pains Jam.
Anhand der Steckdosen erkennt man gleich, dass er schon mal nicht aus Deutschland kommt.
Wow.
Was gibt das denn, wenn es fertig ist?
MonkaS, es tropft.
Das ja war nicht.
Nee, ich weiß nicht, es gibt so ein paar Sachen, die muss man nicht essen.
Jetzt kommt noch eine Kartoffel hinterher.
Jetzt muss er noch ein bisschen flexen, was das Ding kann.
So eine Kartoffel auf dem Fruchteller ist vielleicht nicht das Ding, aber es funktioniert.
Jetzt wird ausgewechselt zu was?
Modulare.
Hat nicht ganz funktioniert.
Und jetzt?
Ich glaube nicht, dass das eigentlich Absicht ist.
Das ist eher so ein Nebenprodukt von der Maschine und es sieht halt cool aus.
Und dann hat es einfach so gelassen.
Oh man, was nicht alles gibt.
Ich finde das immer noch geil in diesen Videos.
Da können wir uns echt jede Woche eins voneinander gucken.
Das hat irgendwie was.
Ich wollte mal gucken, was uns YouTube allgemein empfiehlt.
Juckt mich alles nicht.
Hacker-Mythen.
Oh, das können wir gucken.
Also wir wissen ja, dass Hacker prinzipiell in dunklen Umgebungen arbeiten und einen Hoodie aufhaben.
Und natürlich nicht zu vergessen, grün auf schwarz Schrift verwenden.
Warum habe ich eigentlich im Chat?
Warum habe ich eigentlich den unanimierten Hacker-Man?
Warum habe ich nicht den animierten Hacker-Man im Chat?
Da, man wird es nie wissen.
YouTube hat jetzt ja die komplett neue Kategorie hier am Start seit ein paar Wochen.
Weil ich den ganzen Tag nichts anderes als Corona-News sehen will.
Wie heißt das Hacker-Emote?
Hacker-Mans.
Moment, da haben wir doch schon mal was geguckt.
Genau, der Typ, der irgendwie ein bisschen Strom gewinnen wollte aus dem Abwasser von seinem Regengrille.
AI-Learns-to-Play-Tetris.
Soll die AI mal machen.
Macht die auch ohne uns.
Which duct tape brand is the best?
Tesa.
Aber ich glaube Tesa geht nicht als Duck Tape durch, oder?
Windows XP with all sound reversed.
Okay, warum?
Warum existiert dieses Video?
Wer ist auf die Idee gekommen, hat sich gedacht, das ist eine gute Idee.
3M habe ich auch ein paar Sachen von, ja?
Warum gibt es das Video?
Ich verstehe die Daseinsberechtigung nicht.
Die N64-Vorstellung von 1996-90 ist eine Stunde lang.
Ich verstehe den Sinn des Videos nicht, aber nice, dass es das gibt.
Was machen eigentlich die Games?
Nicht die Games da, die Games kommen dieses Jahr.
Gamescom Opening Night, 27.8.
Oh, die ist jetzt nur online.
Na dann.
Interessiert wahrscheinlich keinen.
Was da stand, doch Canceled?
Echt?
Nee.
Also ich predikte jetzt mal was.
Ich glaube, Gamescom Online interessiert keinen.
Weil die Gamescom ist ja nur irgendwie keine Messe, wo es wahnsinnig tolle Neuigkeiten gibt.
Es gibt ab und zu mal was.
Zum Beispiel kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
Und das fand ich auch cool, dass ich da dabei sein konnte.
Als wir bei Blizzard eingeladen waren, 2017 oder so.
Ich weiß nicht mehr, wann das war.
Wo sie die neue WoW Erweiterung zum ersten Mal auf der Gamescom vorgestellt haben.
Ich interessiere mich null für WoW.
Aber es war lustig, mal zu sehen, wie krass drauf Blizzard-Fanboys sind.
Die sind so abgegangen, als hätten die jetzt irgendwie das Rad neu erfunden.
Vor allem bei der WoW Expansion.
Lull.
Zumindest auf der Gamescom wird ja eh nichts mehr großartig vorgestellt, was relevant wäre.
Zum größten Teil zumindest.
Ein paar Sachen vielleicht.
Aber deswegen ist die Gamescom als News-Plattform irgendwie total uninteressant.
Was bleibt ist, dass es für viele halt mal eine Möglichkeit ist, ein Event zu besuchen,
was sich eben um ihr Hobby dreht und mal wieder ein paar Leute treffen, die sie sonst nicht sehen.
Also Gamescom ist glaube ich für viele mehr so Social Event als Gaming-Messe in Deutschland.
Dazu kommt, dass die Gamescom mittlerweile zur Hälfte irgendwie Influencer-Fan treffen ist.
Was wiederum witzig ist, weil die Gamescom auf der einen Seite sagt, sie wollen davon weniger,
aber ohne können sie ja auch nicht.
Ne, die wissen nicht so genau, was sie wollen.
Ja und dazu kommt, dass die Gamescom offline viel, viel zu voll ist mittlerweile.
Und jedes Jahr voller wird.
Also die war schon vor 5 Jahren oder so viel zu voll.
Und jetzt ist sie, jetzt platzt sie quasi.
Ja also ich glaube, Gamescom Online, Hard of Gaming, Gamescom Online wird wahrscheinlich keinen interessieren.
Weil ich mir auch vorstellen könnte, sie werden das komplett verkacken mit dem Programm.
Wahrscheinlich musst du dir noch irgendein Ticket kaufen oder sowas.
Würde mich nicht wundern, dass du irgendwie ein Gamescom Ticket brauchst, dass du das gucken kannst.
Die wollen ja was verdienen.
Oder anscheinend nicht.
Wobei man halt sagen muss, sie hätten ja die Chance, das gescheit zu produzieren.
Weil die haben in Köln ja auch die ESL setzen und die ESL weiß zumindest halbwegs, wie man so kramt.
Wie man Streams macht.
Naja, mal gucken.
Ich glaube, es wird keinen interessieren.
Gronkh reagiert auf Bibis Haus.
Nein, das interessiert mich überhaupt nicht.
Was wäre denn jetzt, wenn wir auf dieses Video reagieren?
Das ist dann ein Reaction-Video auf ein Reaction-Video, wo Bibi auf ihr Haus reagiert hat.
Das wäre triple, keg triple U Reaction.
The History of Windows 98, ne, wir müssen es ja nicht übertreiben.
Okay, irgendwie empfiehlt uns YouTube heute keine interessanten Videos.
Da müssen wir irgendwas anderes gucken.
Wir gucken jetzt 10 Hacker-Mythen.
Dann brauchst du aber ReactOS. Oh, da war wirklich Payne's Jam.
Ja, Müller, Joe, Gamescom ist auch übelst langweilig.
Überhaupt ist Gamescom viel zu voll, viel zu laut und viel zu überladen.
Und so, dass du als normaler Besucher, der einfach nur hingeht und sagt, ah, ich guck mir mal ein paar Games an, nichts angucken kannst.
Richtig, richtig kacke eigentlich.
Das Einzige, was ich an der Gamescom cool fand, war, dass man mal ein paar Leute gesehen hat, damals, als ich noch YouTube gemacht hab, so in grauer Vorzeit, die man nur online kannte.
Und dass, wenn man ein paar Termine gemacht hat, was man muss ohne Termine, Gamescom ist komplett für'n Arsch, dass man halt auch mal mit ein paar Entwicklern, konnte man nicht reden.
Außer mit den Entwicklern von ARK, als sie noch neu waren.
Und die waren echt begeistert von dem Game.
Meistens sitzt man da mit irgendwelchen Marketing-Leuten zusammen.
Da hat man ein bisschen Kontakt mit den Entwicklern bzw. den Spieleherstellern, hat ein bisschen Sachen sich angucken kann.
Aber ansonsten ist Gamescom einfach ultra-langweilig.
Okay, die 10 Hacker-Mythen.
In der Hacker-Community an sich gibt es viele Mythen.
Ich möchte in diesem Video 10 von ihnen aufgreifen und einen kleinen Reality-Check durchführen.
Der erste Mythos, der sich hartnäckig hält, ist, dass ein Black-Hat-Hacker, also ein Hacker, der illegal hackt, mehr verdient als ein White-Hat-Hacker.
Das muss nicht unbedingt sein, gerade jetzt, in der heutigen Zeit, wo es so viele Bounty-Programme gibt.
Er hört sich ein bisschen Resident-Sleeper an.
Komm, Leute, es sind 8 Minuten, die Chance geben wir immer jetzt.
In diesem Zusammenhang verdienen.
Nun, meiner Ansicht nach verdient ein Black-Hat-Hacker in den meisten Fällen ein Strafverfolgungsverfahren,
der die Unwissenheit anderer Personen ausnutzt, um sich widerrechtlich an ihnen zu bereichern.
Gemeint ist aber natürlich, was ein Black-Hat-Hacker gegenüber einem White-Hat-Hacker monetär einfahren kann.
Wenn man sich typische Gehälter von Penetrationstestern, die quasi die Gruppe der White-Hat-Hacker repräsentieren, anschaut,
dann sieht man, dass sie jährlich in etwa 60.000€ verdienen können.
Top-Verdiener schaffen das sogar auf über 100.000€ im Jahr.
Das muss ein Black-Hat-Hacker erstmal schaffen.
Natürlich gibt es vereinzelte Jobs, die ihn kurzfristig reich machen können,
doch es schwebt ständig das Damocles-Schwert der Ermittlungsbehörden über einem.
Wenn man nebenbei noch Bug-Bounties erhält, weil man Sicherheitslücken in Web-Anwendungen von Unternehmen findet,
dann kann man dieses Gehalt zusätzlich durch legale Hacking-Aktionen aufstocken.
Ich bin der festen Überzeugung, dass es nur selten vorkommt, dass ein Black-Hat-Hacker langfristig mehr verdient als ein White-Hat-Hacker.
Kurzfristig aber schon, wenn man beispielsweise irgendeinen PayPal-Account kapern kann.
Der zweite Mythos befasst sich mehr oder weniger mit der Macht von Hackern.
Dazu habe ich ja auch schon mal in einem Video was gesagt.
Kompletter Schwachsinn.
Hackern wird voll.
Man kann, wenn man da philosophisch rangeht, kann man sagen, wenn die Sachen lukrativ genug sind,
dann werden sie irgendwann gehackt oder andersrum gesagt.
Wer unendlich Zeit und Energie und Geld und sonst was hat, wird alles...
Aber das ist ja nicht lo. Das ist ja unrealistisch.
Können sie nicht. Totaler Blödsinn. Können sie nicht.
Vor allem von Personen, die sich nicht wirklich mit der Materie auskennen, nachgesagt, dass sie alles hacken.
Schwachsinn.
Dass das nicht der Fall ist, sollte jedem schnell klar werden, denn andernfalls würde die gesamte Welt bereits im Chaos-Haus sein.
In der heutigen Zeit ist quasi alles irgendwie miteinander vernetzt und viele Prozesse laufen nur noch elektronisch ab.
Dazu zählen auch Prozesse in kritischen Infrastrukturen wie Krankenhäusern und Telekommunikationsdienstleistern.
Wenn ein Hacker wirklich alles hacken könnte, würde man schon längst wieder Arztbriefe auf Papier schreiben
und Ordecodes Nachrichten übertragen.
Ein Funken Wahrheit steckt aber dennoch in diesem Mythos.
Die Verschlüsselung im Internet basiert nämlich auf mathematischen Einwegfunktionen,
wie die bislang noch kein effizienter Algorithmus gefunden werden konnte, der in hinreichend kurzer Zeit diese Probleme lösen kann.
Das diskrete Logarithmusproblem oder die Faktorisierung von Priemzahl sind hier als bekannte Vertreter zu nennen.
Priemzahl-Faktorisierung.
...ein effizienter Algorithmus vor eines dieser Probleme zu finden, löst er nicht...
Akenas990, 5 Monate, absolute BigBrain-Subscriber, genau so wie du es sagst hier.
Exzellent, und wen haben wir da noch?
Den Thomascool110, 5 Monate und abonniert 3 Monate in Folge.
IQ steigt heute Morgen wieder, steil an.
Stonks IQ.
Also gebe ich ihm recht, das ist kompletter Schwachsinn diese Aussage, Hacker können alles hacken.
Wenn ich, jetzt mal, das einfachste, simpelste Beispiel, was mir einfällt, ja,
wenn ich jetzt irgendwas, irgendein Dokument habe, wo, was drinne steht, was wert ist gehackt zu werden, ja,
irgendwie das super Secret, auf was die Menschheit gewartet hat, ja,
das steht bei mir in irgendeinem Textdokument und ich lege dieses Textdokument auf den USB-Stick
und ziehe den USB-Stick ab und leg ihn bei mir hin.
Dann ist das erstmal nicht hackbar im klassischen Sinne.
Doch, doch, Schwachsinn, was ich sagen muss, dann ist das nur im klassischen Sinne hackbar,
nämlich dass einer bei mir einbricht.
So, also so richtig, echt, so durchs Fenster und so, ja,
aber dann ist der nicht hackbar im eigentlichen Sinne,
weil der USB-Stick liegt abgezogen irgendwo in der Ecke, also man kann nicht alles hacken,
ja, Sie Schwachsinn, ja.
...NP-Problem, sondern macht das Internet zu einem offenen Buch.
Solange diese Probleme nicht gelöst werden, kann ein Hacker zwar viele Angriffsvektoren nutzen,
um an sein Ziel zu gelangen, doch der Großtau wird in der Praxis...
DOOR PREACH!
Die machen, genau, bei mir wird das Door gepreached in Zeitlupe und dann holen sie sich den USB-Stick.
...wann man sowieso reich wird, wenn man das PNP-Problem löst.
Dafür muss man das dann nicht für illegale Zwecke einsetzen.
Man bekommt schon genug Ruhm und Anerkennung dafür.
Viele glauben, dass es Hackern nur ums Geld geht.
Wenn du dir mein Video zu den verschiedenen Hüten, die sich ein Hacker aufsetzen kann angesehen hast,
dann weißt du, dass es neben Geld darum geht es vor...
Nö, absolut, nee, gar nicht, ist es, ist es gar nicht.
Die meisten Leute interessieren sich einfach dafür.
Vor allem den Blackhat-Hackern noch weitere Motivationen wie etwa Spaß, Anerkennung oder Neugier gibt.
Der Hacker, der jüngst den Instagram-Account von Mercedes gekapert hat,
war bestimmt nicht finanziell motiviert, sondern wollte vielleicht Anerkennung von seinen Idolen
oder einfach nur Aufmerksamkeit.
Auch Ragelöste motiviert viele Hacker dazu, anderen zu schaden.
Zudem kann es politische Beweggründe dafür geben, sich vor den Bildschirmen zu setzen und fremde Systeme einzudrängen.
Wenn man an Hacken denkt, dann kommen einem sofort die Bilder von dunklen Gestalten mit Kapuzen in den Sinn,
die als kriminelle dargestellt werden.
In der Welt des Hackers gibt es natürlich noch schwarze Schafe,
doch im Kern handelt es sich bei einigen um jemanden, der einen Gegenstand kreativ zweckentfremdet
und ihm eine neue Bedeutung zuführt.
Populär sind zum Beispiel auch sogenannte Live-Hacks, bei denen man versucht, kreative Lösungen...
Da gibt es ein paar coole Wots von Live-Hacks,
wo manche Leute ziemlich überrascht sind, wie schnell man...
Keine Ahnung, was gibt es denn da?
Irgendwelche RFID-Chips auf irgendwelche Karten auslesen kann, oder sowas.
Übrigens noch mal zu dieser Geschichte,
diesem PP und NP-Problem,
wenn ich das aus dem Kopf richtig zusammenkriege noch, was das gewesen ist,
das ist... ich glaube, das ist irgendwas aus der Mengenlehre,
wo es darum geht, P ist irgendwie die Menge aller Probleme, die sich lösen lassen
oder die sich in sinnvoller Zeit lösen lassen,
und NP ist die Menge der Probleme,
die man quasi überprüfen kann, ob sie richtig gelöst sind.
Stimmt das? Hat da irgendwie eine Ahnung von?
So, und die Frage ist, ob diese beiden Mengen gleich sind oder ungleich.
Also sprich, die Menge der Probleme, die sich in sinnvoller Zeit lösen lassen,
ob das gleich oder ungleich der Menge ist der Lösung,
also der Problem, die man überprüfen kann, ob sie korrekt gelöst sind.
Irgendwie so.
Auch diesen Bereich kann man dem Hacking zuordnen,
wobei man den Problem kaum als illegal bezeichnen würde.
Als Faustregel kannst du dir merken,
wenn du nicht die Erlaubnis besitzt, in ein System einzudringen,
dann ist dein Handeln illegal.
Klingt ziemlich einfach, ist es auch.
Wenn du jedoch die Erlaubnis eines Unternehmens hast,
auf ihrem System...
Oh, der Big Brain Chat-Talk, jetzt geht's ab.
Das hätte ich jetzt nicht sagen sollen.
Aber ich bin immer wieder begeistert, wieviel exzellent High IQ Leute mir im Chat haben.
Das liegt nur an den Subscriber.
Ohne Subscriber wäre das hier angesagt.
Mit Subscriber ist das hier angesagt.
Das stimmt.
Ja klar.
Ich darf auch... Viele tun immer so nach dem Motto,
oh nee, das darf man nicht machen.
Zum Beispiel an eigenen Geräten, wenn ich mir die gekauft habe.
Also wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel meine Playstation Vita flasche,
frage ich nicht, ob man überhaupt von Hacking reden kann,
aber viele Leute würden da wahrscheinlich von Hacking reden.
Ich sag's nicht illegal, das darf ich machen, das ist überhaupt kein Ding.
Ob ich das jetzt live auf Twitch streamen darf,
das ist, glaube ich, so eine Grauzone.
Aber was ich definitiv nicht auf Twitch streamen darf,
ist die IHK Abschlussprüfung.
Weil wir in Deutschland sind.
Und Abschlussprüfung vor einem Ausbildungsberuf super secret ist
und jemand Geld damit verdienen will.
Also jeder alles, ja, aber ich frage wie gut.
Ein gewisses Talent und ein gewisses Brain gehört bei manchen Sachen schon dazu.
Und das wichtigste ist eigentlich, dass man sich dafür interessiert.
Und ich würd mal sagen, es kommt oftmals zusammen.
Leute, die sich für logische Zusammenhänge interessieren
oder eben auch letztendlich für sowas hier,
das sind in der Regel Leute, die zumindest nicht ganz doof sind.
Das kommt, glaube ich, so ein bisschen das Eins zum Anderen.
Also, noch mal, Chantal aus dem Arbeitsamt-Kurs
wird jetzt vielleicht nicht unbedingt auf die Idee kommen.
Ich werd jetzt Hacker.
Tainsa hat mir schon wieder ein Abo geschenkt hier.
Und zwar an Nothing Hacker, er hat nichts.
Jetzt häffst du wenigstens in vier Emotes.
Danke schön für das Subgift.
Ist er Abo-Häver, ist er jetzt Subscription-Häver.
All in Keeper XY.
Ja, also genau, das muss ich aber sagen.
Ich glaube, da kommt oftmals eins zum anderen.
Also sprich, dass Leute, die sich dafür interessieren
und dadurch, dass sie sich für dieses Themengebiet interessieren,
eh schon nicht ganz so blöde sind.
Also, prinzipiell nicht erforderlich, aber ich glaube,
bei den meisten, die sind trotzdem nicht ganz blöd.
Angriffstechniken beherrscht kommt man
in Vorstellungsgesprächen für entsprechende Stellen schon sehr weit.
Das stimmt.
Der Schein trügt also.
Zudem gibt es ja auch noch die Script-Kiddies,
die zwar auch zur Klasse der Hacker zählen,
aber wenigstens gar kein technisches Know-how mitbringen.
Und, wenn man sieht, wie naiv sie teilweise sind.
Das Video ist, glaube ich, simpler,
könnte das Video nicht gemacht sein.
Blackscreen und einfach weißen Text drauf.
Triffendurchführen sind nicht unbedingt
die hellsten Kerzen auf der Torte.
Wenn man sich Hacker-Filme wie Who Am I
oder Passwort Swordfish anschaut,
dann bekommt man leider ein völlig falsches Bild
vom Hacken vermittelt.
In bunten Oberflächen, auf denen in atemberaubender Geschwindigkeit
Code-Zeilen von links nach rechts und oben nach unten sausen,
gibt es in der Realität meistens nur ein paar Konsolenfenster,
auf denen ein normaler Tippgeschwindigkeit
verschiedene Befehle eingetippt werden.
Wenn du dir KaliLinux,
das ist eine Linux-Distribution,
die speziell für Pentester entwickelt wurde, herunterlädst,
dann wirst du auch kaum Tools mit optisch ansprechenden...
KaliLinux ist ja eh schon für die absolut 11-Hat-Leute.
Anwendungen, die für das Hacken von Systemen gedacht sind,
müssen nicht toll aussehen, sondern effizient und zuverlässig laufen.
Übrigens, eine gute Serie, die einen halbwegs realistischen Einblick
in die Welt des Hackens ermöglicht, ist Mr. Robot.
Wo halten sich Hacker in ihrer Feizzeit?
Ich hab's schon talauf gesagt, Mr. Robot,
die erste Hälfte der ersten Staffel ist ziemlich gut.
Danach geht's viel mehr darum, dass der Hauptdarsteller Dachschaden hat.
Halt auf, wo treffen sie sich?
Doch bestimmt in Darknet.
Nein, Hacker treffen sich nicht nur im Darknet,
um neue Angriffstechniken auszutauschen,
sondern auch in normalen Tech-Forum.
Der Informationsaustausch findet sogar hier auf YouTube statt,
wie du beispielsweise an meinem Kanal siehst.
Dieser Mythos hält sich vermutlich immer noch,
dass Hacking grundsätzlich illegal ist.
Aber du weißt es ja mittlerweile zum Glück besser.
Hacker treffen sich auch nicht nur online,
sondern auch auf großen Hacker-Events,
beim CCC oder bei anderen IT-Interessierten zu Hause.
Man kann auch mittlerweile seine Hacking-Fähigkeiten
bei sogenannten CTFs unter Beweis stellen.
Das hat doch etwas mit Computern zu tun.
Das finde ich eigentlich ziemlich cool,
dass auf YouTube mittlerweile sowohl competitive Programming
als auch Capture the Flag-Security-Sachen
durchaus die ein oder anderen Viewer erreichen.
Das finde ich richtig nice.
Ich glaube, vor fünf Jahren gab es sowas auf YouTube nicht.
Aber mittlerweile gibt es Channels,
die haben tausende Aufrufe mit Security, CTF-Geschichten,
competitive Programming und sonst was.
Das finde ich nice, dass es mittlerweile dafür Abnehmer gibt.
Zu tun. Hacker haben also bestimmt alle Informatik studiert.
Ne. Falsch gedacht.
Hacking beschränkt sich nicht nur auf Web-Anwendungen
und Softwareprodukte, sondern auch auf Hardware-Geräte
und die menschliche Psyche.
Demnach ist es nicht verwunderlich,
dass Hacker aus den verschiedensten Bereichen kommen.
Bei Stellenbeschreibungen wird zwar immer wieder
das Informatikstudium genannt,
doch auch Elektrotechniker, Mathematiker, Physiker
und Ingenieure können sich bei entsprechender Art
auf solche Stellen bewerben.
Wir haben uns ja gestern wieder ein bisschen Spaß an der Freude
ein paar Stellenanzeigen angeguckt.
Das ist eher so ein Richtwert.
Letztendlich ist es denen scheißegal,
wenn du es in deinem Gebiet hast,
dann werden die außer vielleicht,
es ist irgendwas staatliches,
aber jeder, der noch halbwegs bei Verstand ist,
wird dann nicht sagen,
wie sie das machen, das 10 Jahre und kennen sich gut aus.
Ah, aber sie haben die falsche Note
im Zeugnis stehen von vor 20 Jahren.
Ne, ne, dann können wir sie nicht nehmen.
Das wäre ja komplett
low brain bescheuert.
Außer es ist irgendeine staatliche Stelle,
da die haben sie eh nicht mehr, was das angeht.
Man muss auch nicht immer ein Studium abgeschlossen haben,
um in diesem Bereich tätig werden zu können.
In vielen Fällen reicht auch eine Ausbildung
oder ein Quereinstieg mit vorangegangener
autodidaktischer Weiterqualifizierung.
Autodidaktischer Weiterqualifizierung.
Exzellent.
Das ist mal eine schöne Wortkombination.
Die gefällt mir.
Wenn man an einen Hacker denkt, dann assoziiert man
mit der Person, die hinter ihm steht,
häufig fette Nerds mit Brille. Auch das ist ein Mythos.
Ja, das stimmt.
Es gibt schließlich nicht nur die rein technischen Hacks,
sondern auch andere Bereiche, wie etwa das Social Engineering.
Da der Mensch die größte Schwachstelle...
Aber es gibt schon einige, die ziemlich...
Also, es gibt viele,
die ziemlich klischeemäßig aussehen.
So ist es jetzt auch nicht.
Man kann jetzt nicht behaupten, das wäre das komplette Gegenteil davon.
Nein, das sind nicht alle.
Und auch bei Weitem
sind auch jetzt nicht irgendwie 99%.
Aber viele sehen wirklich schon
ziemlich stereotypisch aus.
Als Umfeld ist,
sind Angriffe auf dem...
Guckt euch mal die Vorträge beim
CCC und sowas an.
Da sieht man, es sind nicht alle, klar.
Aber ein Großteil sieht schon echt...
Ich nehme mich da ja nicht aus.
Sehen schon echt
stereotypisch aus.
Menschen als soziales Wesen
viel, viel versprechender als die Penetrationsversuche
bei Computersystemen.
Wenn man bei einem Social Engineering Angriff
als sozial isolierter Nerd auftritt,
dann hat man wenig Chancen...
Das stimmt, das ist richtig.
... sind oft Menschen mit einer charismatischen
Ausstrahlung und einer sehr guten
Menschenkenntnis. Da auch für das Hacken
von Computersystemen muss man kein Nerd sein.
Genauso wie man kein Nerd sein muss, um sein
Informatikstudium erfolgreich abschließen zu können.
Einige glauben, dass Hacken reine Männersache ist.
Doch das stimmt nicht.
Mittlerweile gibt es da einige, ja.
Sie sind zwar wie in fast allen Tech-Bereichen
in der Minderheit, da kann man sich ja natürlich
auch die Frage stellen, warum eigentlich,
doch sie sind nicht weniger gehalten.
Oh ne, das Thema sprechen wir jetzt nicht an.
Sonst geht's wieder los.
Nein, nein, das lassen wir
links liegen, das Thema heute.
Im Umfeld des bereits angesprochenen Social Engineering
können sie aufgrund ihrer
Angehensweise an Probleme und ihrer Ausstrahlung
herangehensweise an Probleme
erst mal BoopCam einschalten.
Easy. Donation.
... geeignet sein als ihre männlichen Kollegen.
Das geht aber natürlich... Da hat er recht,
da hat er vollkommen recht, ja.
Es gibt auch brillante technisch versierte Frauen.
Bedenke, dass Ada Loveless als Frau
die erste Informatikerin... PC-lustig, wahrscheinlich nicht.
... eigene Bezeichnung für einen weiblichen Hacker,
nämlich Hexe. Das deutet bereits darauf hin,
dass es eine nicht zum Verlangen...
Ich dachte, Hexe macht Battlefield-Videos.
... weiblichen Hackern gibt.
Vielen Dank fürs Zusehen.
Solltest du weitere Fragen haben, kannst du sie
gerne unten in den Kommentaren posten.
Bis zum nächsten Video.
Passt, da ist das Video.
Kann man sich,
zwar ein paar Punkte kann man diskutieren, aber im
Großen und Ganzen, ja, würde ich, würde ich, sehe ich, sehe ich genauso.
So.
Was haben wir denn alles, was gucken wir uns
als nächstes an?
Ein bisschen was
nicht so bigbrainig ist.
Battlefield. Komm, wir gucken
eine Runde Battlefield, Leute.
Oder Bauer
testet die neue Intel-CPU,
die tausendfurchtausend Euro
für ausgeben muss, für ein FPS
mehr.
Exzellent.
Ok, komm, wir gucken, wir gucken eine Runde Battlefield.
Best Moments.
Der hat sogar Top Plays rausgehauen.
Das ist jetzt der Best,
von den Besten ist das.
Max, was sagst du zu Python?
Inwiefern?
Also was genau
willst du wissen? Ich meine, es ist eine
von zigtausend Programmiersprachen.
Eine der bekannteren.
Eine der beliebtesten zur Zeit.
Eine der
aktuell auch angesagtesten.
Gerade was Machine Learning und solche
Geschichten angeht.
Ansonsten bin ich persönlich
jetzt nicht so der Riesen-Python-Fan.
Ich kann's lesen, ich kann's schreiben,
aber
ist jetzt nicht das, wenn ich die Auswahl hätte,
was ich nehme, was ich nehmen würde.
Ja, das...
Ja, jetzt hab ich eigentlich schon alles gesagt, ja.
Ich bin...
Ich mag das mit den Eindrückungen nicht.
Muss ich euch ehrlich sagen. Es ist nicht...
Es ist eigentlich das, was mich am meisten nervt.
Ich bin einfach
Klammern-Fanboy.
Was das angeht.
Ich mag Klammern um meine
Blocks.
Wird eigentlich Pascal noch benutzt?
Äh, bestimmt irgendwo. Ich meine,
Cobol wird auch noch benutzt.
Würdest du dich eher für
Holy Sea entscheiden? Holy Sea ist ja quasi
so ein
Subset von C. Keine eigene
Sprache, sondern quasi eher so Guides.
Wie sollte man C verwenden?
Ich glaube, für C braucht man keine Guides.
Also keine
Einschränkungen mehr.
C kann schon so wenig.
Da kann man ruhig alles benutzen, was da ist.
Und die Erweiterungen bei C sind auch recht
sinnvoll die letzten Jahre gewesen.
Beispielsweise dieser Struct-
Initializer und sowas. Kannste dich echt nicht
beschweren. Also man muss sagen, im Vergleich zum C++
Gremium wird C
mit bedacht und sinnvollen Sachen
weiterentwickelt.
Luku sagt,
ich habe eben mit Python angefangen. Es ist eine super
Sprache zum Einstieg. Eines der besten Sprachen, die man
zum Einstieg sich angucken kann.
Aber generell, wenn man anfängt mit
Programmieren, sollte man sich überlegen,
was will man machen. Also sprich, wenn man jetzt
zum Beispiel Windows Desktop
Anwendungen machen will, ist Python vielleicht nicht die
beste Wahl. Oder
wenn man irgendeine Webseite
machen will, dann ist Python vielleicht
auch nicht die erste Wahl.
Weil man braucht nach wie vor
HTML, CSS und JavaScript fürs Frontend.
Aber im Backend kann man es wunderbar verwenden.
Sie fragen, was man machen will. Aber es ist auf jeden Fall
eine super Einstiegsprogrammiersprache.
Was ist deine Lieblingsprogrammiersprache?
Die Kombination aus.NET Core
und C Sharp gefällt mir mit
Abstand. Wirklich mit riesem Abstand
am besten. Es gibt für mich nichts,
was ich für mich
so angenehm zu programmieren und zu
entwickeln anfühlt wie.NET Core
mit C Sharp.
Eines der nutzlosen
C-Features ist Generic.
Habe ich noch nie verwendet.
Ich habe letztens mal einen Blogpost
über Generic gelesen.
Da kannst du irgendwelche
Typumwandlungsgeschichten machen.
Ich bekomme es aus dem Kopf nicht mehr zusammen.
Habe ich mir nicht angeguckt.
Aber ich könnte mir vorstellen,
wenn man es mal braucht, ist es gut, dass es da ist.
Hast du schon Doom Eternal
gezockt? Ja, ich fand es ziemlich gut.
Ziemlich gut.
Es hat ein bisschen
Anlaufschwierigkeiten, Doom Eternal, finde ich.
Aber
wenn man mal so 2-3 Stunden
gespielt hat, wird das richtig gut.
Ja,
Louis Q,
dann ist das für dich
exakt die
beste Programmiersprache zum Anfang
und du kannst sie auch länger
fristig verwenden.
So.
Also gucken wir uns mal aktuelle
Battlefield Plays an.
Wird ja mal wieder Zeit.
Exzellent.
Top.
Äh, kannst du gute Projekte
für Einsteiger empfehlen? Ich habe letztens auf
GitHub was gesehen, wo jemand
ähm,
ne Sammlung hatte für Einsteigerprojekte.
GitHub Program...
Vorschläge für Beginnerprojekte habe ich letztens auf
github.de
gesehen.
Vorschläge für Beginnerprojekte habe ich letztens auf
GitHub gesehen.
Vor Beginners, Beginners Project. Musst du
mal suchen.
Project Lists.
Gibt's jede Menge Vorschläge.
Ähm, wo es natürlich
ums Üben geht. Jetzt nicht unbedingt
so sehr, dass da was rauskommt, was du am Endeffekt
äh, groß verwenden kannst
oder vielleicht sogar
verkaufen, aber verkaufen kann man eh das wenigste.
Verkaufen kann man nur
irgendwie dieses Business Zeug, was die Leute
brauchen.
Ich überlege gerade, was ist so das
schönste Beginnerprojekt?
Also ich denke, es hängt ein bisschen von der
Sprache ab, was du machst.
Ähm, was, was ein gutes Beginnerprojekt ist.
Python, Python.
Ja gut, wenn du, wenn, Python Beginnerprojekt,
äh, wo Python ja total angesagt ist,
ist grad im Bereich AI.
Ich weiß nicht, was es da für schöne Beginnerprojekte
gibt. Ähm,
ich würd, ich würd wirklich mit den Basics
anfangen, wie man heutzutage so schön
sagt. Die, die Basics, das ist das
wichtigste.
Haha, what the fuck?
Was machen die denn da auf dem Boden, Alter?
Das ist gestellt, oder?
Ist das gestellt?
Ich weiß nicht, das,
das könnte schon ein bisschen Setup sein.
Das könnte schon ein bisschen Setup sein.
Also so, so dumm,
so dumm und, und,
aber ist trotzdem lustig irgendwie.
Nee, das ist gestellt, das muss
gestellt sein, Alter.
Das, oh, das war schon geil,
das war schon geil.
Oh, es ruckelt.
Ah, nee, das ist nochmal eine Zeitlupe.
Oh, blup.
Vielleicht war es auch doch nicht gestellt.
Aber es, es sah schon
irgendwie sehr gestellt aus.
Boom. Fall, was
hat der für einen Foff? Was ist das für ein Foff?
Foff 250, oder
was?
Der fliegt voll rein,
der fliegt voll rein.
Erstmal schön 360'd.
Der fliegt voll rein mit dem Chat.
Das sieht man jetzt schon.
Bam. Nee, doch nicht.
Irgendwas anderes ist reingeflogen.
Der Typ ist immer den gleichen Text
vor. Ja, es ist immer exakt das gleiche,
was er erzählt.
Ah, exzellent Grafikglitches.
Boah.
Cool.
Das war das Beste an Battlefield
3 und 4. Die Fahrzeugphysik,
ja. Kennt ihr noch die
fliegenden LAVs und sowas?
Bam.
Exzellent.
Der Heli, der Heli hält
auch nichts von normal fliegen, oder?
B29
Korn, 10 Monate.
Oh, oh, oh, jetzt hier.
Exzellent Subscription. Dankeschön für den Sub.
An der Stelle ist mir mal was passiert.
Das muss ich gerade mal zeigen.
Wie hieß man...
Ich hab noch mal einen zweiten Channel gemacht
auf YouTube, wo ich hier
ab und zu mal ein paar
Battlefield Clips und Zeug gepostet hab
vor Jahren.
Da gab's was Cooles,
ähm...
...
Da erinnere ich mich heute noch dran, an dieses Schwachsinnstod.
Einfach voll gegen die Mauer gedüst, warum auch immer.
Äh, wo ist das Battlefield-Video?
Bestimmt lag, ja wahrscheinlich, aber ich bin einfach gerade ausgelaufen und auf einmal
beschleunigt es mich und schlägt mich gegen die Wand.
Das ist Konsole, oder er hat Motionblur an, eins von beiden.
Das ist typisches Konsole in Motionblur, ja Playstation.
Zack, oh der Heli kriegst dick.
Äh, what?
Der hat den Jet abgeschossen!
Das war aber, das war einfach nur Glück.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, exellent.
Ich weiß das immer gar nicht so richtig zu würdigen, weil ich halt nix, kein Jet, noch Heli fliege.
Der Road killt jetzt, der Road killt jetzt Leute auf dem Dach.
Ich glaub den Clip haben wir schon mal in abgewandelter Form woanders gesehen.
Die denken sich da drin jetzt auch, what the fuck, Alter.
Auf einmal steht ein Panzer auf dem Dach.
Get wrecked.
Battlefield physics.
Wenn er den Chat trifft.
Ok, das ist heftig.
Es ist halt mega Glück, wenn er den Chat trifft.
Es ist mega Glück, aber trotzdem übelst krass.
So ein Schwachsinn ging echt nur Battlefield 3 und 4.
So geil, der Road kill Typ, der hat sich auch gedacht, das kann jetzt nicht echt passiert sein, oder?
Auf dem Dach in Flatzone.
Ich mein man darf jetzt nicht davon ausgehen, dass das reproduzierbar geht.
Also, die haben das wahrscheinlich 200 Games probiert und das sind alle Clips, die sie rausgekriegt haben davon.
Der Panzer bringt dir hier oben drauf überhaupt nichts, weil du nicht nach unten schießen kannst.
Es ist komplett sinnlos den Panzer auf dem Dach zu haben.
Ja, stimmt, das ist cool.
Okay, das ist auch gut.
long range anti air shots
ja, stimmt, das ist cool
as these games with
battlefield 4 probably being
the stand out when it comes to
long range rocket shots
enjoy some absolutely incredible
shots from the community
an a.a.n
im telling you, some of these are
just amazing shots that you've probably
okay, das ist auf gut glück
das ist, das ist halb predicted, aber
auf gut glück, dass er da rein fliegt, bam
das ist, das ist ein richtig
geiles gefühl, wenn man solche shots trifft
richtig poggers
das war auch, das war auch wieder ein satz, oder
den hätte außerhalb von twitch keiner
verstanden, das ist ein richtig geiles gefühl
richtig poggers
firestorm
und
flatsch
bam, der heli fliegt auch
nur geradeaus im
im sparbetrieb
flatsch
zack
den clip haben wir auch schon gesehen, oder
die stehen das ganze game auf dem
strommast oder was das ist und schießen geradeaus
das könnte sein, aber es gab so
wirklich
es könnte sein, dass die absichtlich rein fliegen
aber es gibt momenten, da passiert das wirklich
also, ich würde, denen würde ich jetzt
mal nichts unterstellen, dem am anfang
mit dem motorrad, das sah sehr
nach setup aus
naja, so momenten, das gibt es schon
da tbackt der erstmal ne runde
wir müssen an der stelle nochmal kurz sagen
wie geil parasail storm
aussah als map, vom wetter her
leider finde ich, hat sich parasail storm
gerade in rush, grottenschlecht
gespielt
aber optisch mit den wellen
die map sah wirklich cool aus
ist es nicht auch die map mit dem
high, ist hier nicht auch der high irgendwo gewesen
was denn das für ne grafik, ist das
xbox 360 oder was
ja
die musik im hinterkoller
schau wieder, die hatten wir doch jetzt gerade
Wie oft wollen sie das jetzt noch machen?
Also langsam wären die Shots auch ein bisschen Residenzlieber, ha?
Ich mein die machen die ganze Game nichts anders als den Heli in ihre Rakete fliegen lassen.
Ähm, das ist eine gute Frage.
Der echte Proxy sagt, meinst du, dass Battlefield bald zu alter Form kommen wird?
Cod schafft das ja leider nicht.
Nö.
Ich glaube, die haben keine Ahnung mehr, was sie machen und die Leute, die es wissen, sind nicht mehr da.
Battlefield 5 haben sie nachgebaut, ok wusste ich gar nicht.
Wow, der war cool.
Schon wieder die Typen auf dem Strom was.
Die machen echt den ganzen Tag nichts anderes.
Was mach?
Das glaub ich dem nicht, ey.
Das muss doch sowas, muss doch Setup sein, was macht denn der Heli da oben?
Warum steht der einfach nur da und bewegt sich nicht?
Oh, die Map, ähm, was für eine Map war das nochmal?
Silk Road oder so, ne?
Oder wie hieß das Ding die Map?
Die hat man nicht oft gespielt.
TV-Raket, aber so lang?
Ok, das war cool.
Das muss ich mir grad nochmal angucken, also nicht das.
Das andere, das hier.
Übrigens, der hat schöne, schöne, äh, Color Correction für die Map.
What?
Wie hat er den denn getroffen?
Hä?
Ähm.
Ssack.
Die Musik, Alter.
Aber ich muss euch sagen, das geilste Gefühl in Battlefield war, in Bad Company 2 mit dem
AT-4, ein Vorgang.
Das war ein Vorgang.
In Bad Company 2 mit dem AT-4 einen vollbeladenen Heli abzuschießen.
Das war das Beste.
Und das ging in Battlefield Bad Company 2 auch ziemlich gut, weil die Helis fett waren und langsam.
So einen vollbeladenen Heli mit dem AT-4 in Bad Company 2 rausgelasert.
Das war das Geilste.
Okay.
Ich muss euch sagen, wir haben genug AT-4-Shots.
Das reicht mir jetzt.
Ich will mal ein paar normale Plays sehen.
Okay.
Das ist ja fast...
Manchmal Anfangen mit dem Heli Roadkills zu Machen
Damit Durchgegen gemixt Durchgeschnetzelt
Ist der jetzt einfach für den Swag rausgesprungen oder was? Warum ist der eben aus dem Heli gesprungen?
Warum? Warum ist der eben aus dem Heli gesprungen? Ergibt doch eigentlich überhaupt keinen Sinn, oder? Weil's geht.
Flex
Bäm
Voll im Kopf mit der Panzergranate da
Messer
Das sind, okay, das ist legit, das ist legit
Die Leute sind so dämlich und campen sich den Arsch ab in Battlefield teilweise, dass sie links und rechts nichts mitkriegen
Und jetzt C4, jawoll
Die kriegen echt wieder gar nichts mit, die kriegen gar nichts mit
Aber jetzt kommt der Bot und schießt ihm in den Sack. Nee, fast
Okay, ich glaub das hab ich noch nie gehabt
die löcher bringen wir was das war nice ok der fliegt gleich der fliegt gleich oder
was der lv der wird an der stelle gespawnt oder der lv würde gerade gespawnt vom spiel
oder was macht er da ok das ist feil
die bettel viel eins ne ist gar nicht mehr sei es aus wie bettel viel eins ist es gar nicht
was sehe ich da was sehe ich da das ist jetski oder sowas was ist das für eine map was ist
das für eine map warum fliegt warum fliegt da so ein boot ah locker das ist ps4
kills was
irgendwie ist es cool dass es einfach in bettel viel geht das ist das ist das geile an den
an bettel viel 3 und 4 oder auch teilweise bei komplett 2 dass so ein scheiß einfach
halt geht deswegen gab so vieles so sandbox dinge halt so so so sachen die ungescriptet
einfach passiert sind und das hat halt das das war auch so dass das ist das feeling was
du bei dem game hattest dass die sachen halt nicht so passiert sind weil vorher sich jemand
überlegt hat die müssen so passieren sondern sie sind einfach durch die verketten von von
gameplay aufgedrehten
triff den typ auf der oah das sind anti das sind anti panzer rounds gewesen die fliegen
aber noch übelst langsam ich fand das video von ihm diesmal richtig gut er hat nicht so
viel erzählt das was was das für eine sprache ist das spanisch das armando das ist das
spanisch oder portugiesisch italienisch es ist definitiv nicht französisch das ist
spanisch okay oh huge schnaps guckt euch mal an die kugel ist drei kilometer groß
holen gameplay lull lull oh das war aber ein ein ein nicer snipe kredo das wird nicht
passieren ich glaube nicht dass es dazu führen würde dass das das wieder mehr heute spielen
das war dings hier addon ich hab vergessen wie es heißt war das arm out kill nee war
das war das arm out kill nee arm out kill war battlefield 3 ich bringe es durcheinander
was ist jetzt los was ist jetzt los im italienischen
ja das kann gut sein ja ja das klingt gut die dinger zu treffen das würde ich nie gebacken
kriegen und ja das stimmt battlefield 4 und battlefield 3 sogar bed company 2 irgendwo
die sehen auch heutzutage noch ok aus ist ja nicht so dass es jetzt irgendwie schlecht
wäre zumal ich sehe auf low setting spiel für max fps
battlefield 5 oder support eingestellt ja aber verkackt haben von anfang an mit battlefield
voll in die fresse
er kann sich nicht entscheiden wo er spawned
ok das war glück dass der genoss gehabt hat das war echt glück
und mit ankündigung
springen sie alle raus und und und trifft er nochmal trifft er nochmal das könnte treffen
das könnte treffen ja poggers
der hat der hat ein bisschen bisschen reaction verzögerung kann das sein guck mal der fliegt
hier runter
schießt nochmal
jetzt trifft er
1 2 3 4 der hat 4 sek reaktionszeit wie hat er das überhaupt getroffen
der wird rausgesnipt aus dem cockpit
oh das ist nice ja was zum was ist das was sehe ich hier
was ist das denn
was war das denn
kann mir das irgendeiner erklären
die pots aus final stand es kann sein dass ich das dass ich da nie drinnen war in so
einem
es gab drop pot die map kenne ich noch
ich mein hübsch war das game schon guckt euch das mal an also ich kann mal nix sagen
es sieht immer noch ziemlich gut aus
das ist wieder in den long range
oder erstmal eine runde spray in locker
der gegner die wieder absolut nix checken
und g18 war auch eigentlich ziemlich op aber trotzdem
die gegner sind wieder absolut brain dead
aber so muss das sein
was meint ihr wie meine 30 null free for alls früher in call of duty entstanden sind bestimmt
nicht weil ich so gute gegner hatte
brauchst du brauchst dumme gegner für so plays
ansonsten ist das so ein so ein crap wie in modern warfare wo alle einer einer einer
eins zweier kd haben
im multiplayer im normalen multiplayer
dort da werden sie weggespray in your ass weggespray
das ist ja nice
aber entfug habt das jetzt
ich mein in dem moment denkt ihr dreht euch nicht um dreht euch nicht um dreht euch nicht
um
dreht euch nicht um dreht euch nicht um und jetzt
ok mehr glück als verstand
der heli der markt auch nur geradeaus fliegen in einer linie
ach das sind wieder die typen hier auf dem dixi das ganze game nichts anderes aber wisst
ihr also wenn ich die runde gespielt hätte wird mir das voll auf den keks gehen weil
die haben nicht zum runden win beigetragen definitiv nicht die haben vielleicht mal den
ein oder anderen heli getroffen irgendwann mal aber es waren im prinzip einfach drei
drei wasted slots in im team
tru lulve
schon wieder wie viele rpg kills across the map von der pose haben wir in diesem video
jetzt schon gesehen
ja wenn man ein ganzes game sitzt trifft oder den ganzen tag sitzt trifft man auch mal was
und und jetzt und jetzt und jetzt
so was haben wir jetzt hier noch zur auswahl die härtesten super nintendo spiele der linux
vergleich welche distribution passt für euch da bin ich ja mal gespannt was er sagt
doom eternal nightmare speedruns
das hat nichts mit diesen glitch speedruns zu tun sondern bei die ultra nightmare speedruns
die spielen wirklich das game von anfang bis ende und das ist teilweise echt heftig was
die haben wahnsinnig drauf
dann haben wir noch den auer
irgendwas von linux tech tips wo ich keine ahnung hab warum ich das aufgemacht hab und
was es da geht
this is 15 times faster than your pc holy shit liquid honey bad war honey badger nicht
in ghost ne waffe
what happened to america online haben wir auch noch zu bieten
ja was ok äh was gucken wir wollen wir das was wollen wir gucken
leute macht sagt sagt was
ok speedrun das ist auch kein speedrun das ist ein speedrun erklärungsvideo linux
skelleron twitch prime excellent
ich hab mich grad an nichts verschluckt geht auch
danke schön für den sub
ja gucken wir erst das speedrun videos geht 15 min danach gucken wir das linux video
fast ein intro
er hört sich schon ein bisschen resident sleeper an genau deswegen mag ich die normalen
doom eternal speedruns nicht aber die ultra nightmare speedruns sind richtig nice
die stimme ist ein bisschen resident sleeper
ja aber das gameplay ist ultra nice also ich hab mal nen doom eternal speedrun geguckt
also nen ultra nightmare speedrun das geht irgendwie 2 stunden oder so
und ist wirklich gameplay technisch kannst du siehst du wirklich die leute kamst drauf
ah 3 stunden ich bilde mir ein 2 in 2 stunden
aber können auch 3 stunden sein das genau das ist nicht nur ultra nightmare das ist
100 prozent ultra nightmare also alles sammeln guckt euch das mal an vor allem die müssen
aim haben die müssen den combat flow von diesem game richtig drauf haben die müssen auswendig
lernen wo gegner steht welche waffe man gegen welche gegner verwendet das ist schon nicht
ohne
was sind die besten wepens zu benutzen welchen demonen soll man prioritisieren welche techniken
sind gebraucht um schnellere wepens zu beherrschen in diesem video werden wir diese Fragen beantworten
und mehr
moment ich muss mal kurz die werbung überspringen
ok klar klar anzug auch klar
ok auch logisch
das ist nervig
ok wenn das wichtig ist dass man nach dem level alles durchklickt
alles klar
die haben es echt drauf
ja ihr müsst euch mal vorstellen 2,5 stunden alle upgrades alle waffen unlocks alle tokens
alle alle alle lore codex pages 2,5 stunden so viel habe ich die ersten 3 levels gespielt
oder so
man muss auch sagen die müssen sogar richtig gut aimen können das ist ja auch was was
bei den meisten speedruns jetzt nicht unbedingt so erforderlich ist die müssen viel auswendig
lernen und noch richtig gut aimen können also eigentlich so ein richtiger shooter speedrun
wie man ihn sich wünscht
ok
und man natürlich jetzt auch weniger leben und sowas bekommt dann
heißen die wirklich cacodemons
ist bestimmt einfach nur die englische aussprache
stimmt das müsst ihr ja auch noch machen und was ich ganz vergessen habe was du bei
einem hundert prozent ja auch noch machen musst ist 100 prozent musst du diese ganzen
kämpfe die die zeit die die zeit limit haben auch machen es gibt doch immer zwischendurch
diese diese schlüsseln wo man wo man spezielle kämpfe anlockt mit einem zeit limit muss
ja auch noch alle machen
ok die mussten echt viel auswendig lernen wenn du wenn man doom eternal ultra nightmare
speed runner werden will
sind requirement using the weapon will is also out as it is much quicker to use hotkeys
to switch between each weapon switching between different weapon combinations is extremely
important when it comes to certain combat techniques which we will get into very shortly
when it comes to weapon and suit upgrades sentinel crystals and ruins there are countless different
possibilities for which order you can choose while it's a requirement that everything eventually
gets upgraded certain upgrades are more valuable than others so i chosen first this generally
comes down to player preference however and while tech tree priority may eventually be
demonstrably solved it's far too early right now for everything to be tested thoroughly
players do know exactly which order they will unlock upgrades though and there does seem
to be universal agreement for some of them when it comes to weapon mods generally only
one is used for each weapon as the time spent waiting for the mod to switch ends up being
wasted
for the combat shotgun sticky bombs are used as an effective way to clear weaker mobs
and
this weapon generally stops being used though when the super shotgun is obtained precision
bolt is used for the
i used it too i already have the speedrun strats on it unconsciously i used it too i used it too
i'm telling you max speedrun strats already at the start although he never wanted to speedrun
it as long as ammo is available is the preferred way to combat heavier demons however this
mod tends to be useless until lock on speed is upgraded for the ballista our ballista
is
while the destroyer blade does extremely high aoe damage the fact that you lack any mobility
when charging it makes it a terrible idea to use both mods for the chaingunner used
in their own ways
as a casual viewer combat arenas in doom eternal can look like a chaotic whirlwind a highly
entertaining chaotic whirlwind but one nonetheless however there is way more planning and strategy
involved than you may realize there are a host of different things that speedrunners need
to learn remember and master for each combat arena the player needs to know which enemies
and how many of them will spawn where and when will they spawn what specific triggers activate
each phase of combat what are the movement patterns of each demon
armor and fuel pickups how much ammo will you have before each fight on top of these
specifics they also need to know more generally applicable information how many shots of each
weapon does it take to kill each type of demon which weapons have higher dps and given that
different weapons cause different damage to different demons what is the most optimal
combinations for each one with all of this information understood the top players will
know for each battle which enemies they will kill in which order at which location and
with which weapons this certainly doesn't imply that everything will always go as planned
and things can definitely snowball out of control if mistakes are made but these combat
sections are much more meticulous if they die the run is over because you can't recover
it's gonna take 3-4 minutes
now let's talk about a couple of these specific combat techniques that runners use the first
is already well known and used by all of the top doom players it's almost essential for
beating the game on ultra nightmare and that's weapon switching single fire weapons have
a built-in also man sieht die du musst in dem speed run wirklich aimen können single fire
quickscope here have a built-in cool down limiting the rate at which they can fire however this
cool down is reset whenever the weapon is equipped so by cycling through weapons the rate of
fire can be increased dramatically resulting in a much higher dps ich glaube dass das sowie
die spielen wirklich der weg ist wie sich das entwickler auch gedacht haben wie man das
spiel spielt super shotguns and meat hook is obviously used to pull the slayer around
combat arenas but it also has a much more useful function which is to launch the slayer
to great heights or distances what the fuck monkaS das geht this technique is called
a yeet hook and to do it well takes a lot of precision the frag grenade is a weapon
that should be used as much as possible which ends up being difficult given that there is
so much going on during combat keeping track of the frag grenades cool down is just another
element the player needs to worry about but proper implementation of the grenade is extremely
useful for its extra dps and also to use in specific combinations to kill heavier demons
as i mentioned earlier the rocket launchers lock on mode is the top choice for eliminating
heavier demons some of them need extra damage to be killed so generally another shot with
a precision bolt or super shotgun is used as a whole sang a matter lock on blast plus
a frag grenade is a much better option as once the rockets and grenades have been fired
you can immediately move on to the next demon ballista boosting is also used to move around
quickly and make larger jumps this takes advantage of the large recoil and provides a decent
speed boost when shot while in midair knowing everything there is to know about how enemies
and weapons work is something every runner strives to accomplish but at the end of the
day it all boils down to execution every single missed shot costs time so ultimately accuracy
will reign supreme as the biggest variable the top players have i mean i can i understand
that especially if you haven't played the game that it looks a bit different but the
game is not easy and it's part of the reason or it works as follows you have different
mechanik in dem spiel du kannst wenn die gegner wenn die gegner so golden leuchten kannst du sie killen du
kriegst ein bisschen ich glaube leben du kannst die gegner anzünden und wenn du so killst kriegst
ein bisschen ammo nicht ammo ammo wenn du die gegner schnetzelst mit der kettensäge kriegst
munition und das musst du quasi im passenden rythmus ausführen und auf ultra nightmare sind
die gegner auch viel stärker und du hältst auch insgesamt weniger aus also das ist echt nicht
ohne die sind wirklich ziemlich gut die die die runner combat is so entertaining to watch
when doom eternal is played well it is just beautiful ja das stimmt
ich halte ich verstehe überhaupt nicht was passiert kann alles auf einmal
exzellent
der weiß halt echt überall wo was steht er
und das genau und das muss erst mal zwei stunden durchhalten
der hat es halt voll drauf der du
now i just want to quickly break down a fight which shows some of the combat mechanics in
action this is taken from zero masters ultra nightmare 100% run of two hours and
three minutes in this particular arena there are three waves and while there are plenty of lesser
demons running around at any given time only certain demons need to be killed in order to
complete each wave the first wave consists of two cyber mancubi a revenant and a hell knight the
second wave contains a baron a whiplash and a cacodemon the third wave contains another baron
two whiplashes and a cacodemon
once those demons have been eliminated the arena will open as soon as he enters he will list a
boost to the location of the first spawn a cyber mancubus these demons are protected by high
amounts of armor but are weak to the blood punch which zero master uses to break its armor and
deal significant damage he then switches between the super shotgun and heavy cannon to finish it
off the next target is a revenant where zero master uses the rocket launcher lock and you know
what the coolest thing about it is that it is exactly as the developers thought they
didn't build it up for nothing that the melee attack does something against the armor that that
does something against that just as I go pretty much if that would not look at the developer
he would probably say that's exactly how we imagined it and that's cool if that
really agrees so however he only has two rockets which isn't enough to kill it so he needs to
quick switch to the super shotgun to do more damage he then jumps down and chainsaws the second
cyber mancubus using the chainsaw to eliminate certain heavy demons is embedded into the strategy
but requires a lot of planning as you need to save up the three bars of fuel needed with the
ammo obtained from the mancubus he switches back to the rocket launcher and uses the lock on to
kill the hell knight this begins the second wave and he immediately runs to the spawn of the
baron to take it out with the crucible again saving crucible charges for the head is important
and where each charge will be used is planned in advance unfortunately a glitch occurs here
where the crucible attacks again wasting a charge on an imp there are still a few annoying bugs in
eternal which haven't yet been resolved which can cause some hiccups this wasted charge won't
impact this run immediately but it does mean time will be lost somewhere in a future battle
zero master then uses a lock on to kill the whiplash and an arbalest shot to take out the
cacodemon now there is a slight delay before the next wave spawns look I mean that this shot
for example even if the opponent now moves the fast he has to hit that first
moment when he just had quickscope next to it he had to hit it first followed by a lock on and frag grenade to take out a whiplash he then heads through the portal to the other side of the arena with a second whiplash should be but in this case there were a couple of time losses previously during the fight which meant that it had already moved away he shifts focus to the cacodemon taking it out with the arbalest and then searches for the remaining whiplash which after a few seconds is found and destroyed master 2090
ballern bis die aliens kommen ja aber dazu muss man erst einen klan besuchen nur wenn man einen klan besucht geht das
mit einem lock on in diesem fall war es ein wenig hinter dem schedule keine zerstörungsvolle schmerz
es war nur ein paar sekunden Zeitloss allerdings wenn es nicht so wie geplant ist kann der Kampf schnell aus der Hand
aus der Kontrolle auswählen als ein Bekannter top level Doom Eternal Kampf ist eine von den
most entertaining gameplay out there while the initial wave of excitement over doom eternal seems to have washed away
i believe that competitive play will begin to snowball in popularity as time goes on i've put a link in the description
to zero masters full ultra nightmare 100 run so definitely go and give that one a watch a huge thanks to
zero master as well for letting me use his footage throughout the video the guy is truly an absolute
legend and is in my opinion the greatest doom player of all time i may even devote an entire video to his
accomplishments in the near future thanks again to the guys in the doom eternal also das ist echt nicht ohne
continuing to help me learn more about this game thank you so much for watching you legends i hope
you are having a fantastic day and i will see you in the next video habt ihr das gehört leute wir sind legends einfach nur weil wir das video geguckt haben
aber das wusste ich das wusste ich ja vorher schon chat
aber nice das video
mal kurz speedrun doom eternal ich will mal gucken wie viel views so was überhaupt bekommt also es ist ja so mario 64 speedruns da gab es
übrigens einen neuen world record letztens mario 64 speedruns ist ja eins der bekanntesten kategorien
ich in hunderttausender views ja es gab letztens 900 120 star world record bisschen lang zum gucken
aber übelst bestimmt übelst nice ist der nackig ist der nackig hat er nichts an
dann
okay
das ist gut verstehe ich verstehe ich da kann er schneller seinen controller bewegen wenn er keine reibungs energie
mehr verschwende zwischen seinen klamotten ja ist er ist er wirklich nackig am speedrun sehe ich das
richtig der hat nackig den mario 64 world record speedrun gemacht
nicht schlecht okay er hat bestimmt eine hose an oder so aus die jubel
äh
äh warum gibt es auf speedrun.com keine ultra night mehr
hat er mal einen link zu dem run
okay okay es gibt wenigstens halbwegs ordentlich views die submitten das glaube ich einfach nicht
ach so moment any percent ich habe es nicht gesehen weil mein dark reader die seite kaputt macht ja
aber trotzdem nicht nicht die richtigen nicht das richtige und die laden das wahrscheinlich
wahrscheinlich lassen die das nicht verifizieren weil das video auf youtube war 228
aber trotz ach nee 28 okay dann uploaden die das doch ach was auch immer ist aber nice dass man
wenigstens ein paar views davon bekommt ich komme euch drüber klar dass der dass der nackig dass
der nackig mario 64 gestreamt hat das ist so einfach nackig vom rechner im stream
jono juckt ihr nicht juckt ihr nicht stimmt er hat immerhin eine brille auf
das ist ja ein thema wo ich mich schon auch öfters drüber ausgelassen habe mit welcher
linux distribution kann man anfangen was ist wie hierfür fortgeschrittene was ist dafür da da habe
ich mich auch schon etwas zu ausgelassen mal gucken mal gucken was wieder zu sagen und zwar
linux ist nicht ein system sondern es gibt unfassbar viele linux distributionen ja und
distributionen manche sowas wie alternative systeme es gibt nicht das linux sondern ihr habt
die wahl zwischen sehr sehr vielen dingern die vielleicht zweck gut sind aber für jemand anders
nicht so gut und das kommt stark drauf an was ihr eigentlich machen wollt hast du den half life 1
welt rekord mitbekommen wurde an nebenbei noch ein anderes game gelernt hat nein hast du mal
link habe ich nicht mitbekommen können wir gucken euer system denn eigentlich können soll was eure
hardware von sich gibt und so weiter und so fort das kann man bei windows also wenn du link hast
gucken wir mal rein captain peng du hast deinen ersten raspberry pi bekommen excellent
hast du schon was spezielles vor link finden es gibt ein windows 10 die anderen sind einfach alle
nicht mehr aktuell das ist bei linux anders dadurch dass linux wirklich offen ist und jeder
sich sein eigenes linux erstellen kann link gespeichert da natürlich auch über 200 verschiedene
davon und wir wollen uns heute wirklich einige davon mal angucken ja wie versprochen sehr sehr
viele systeme die wir uns heute ganz kurz alle nur angucken wollen ich werde nicht erklären was die
alle so und das reicht hinten und vorne nicht es gibt noch viel viel viel viel viel mehr anders
macht oder so sondern ich will sie nur ein kleines bisschen einordnen in verschiedene kategorien so
dass ihr vielleicht einen kleinen guide habt welches system für euch am besten geeignet ist das
gesagt hier muss die steve es fehlt noch auch noch dazu sagen alles ist eigentlich mit jedem linux
system möglich ihr habt nicht ein linux das überhaupt nichts kann sozusagen oder ein linux
das echt wo links habe ich gar nicht gesehen excellent ich meine ich kenne niemand der steam os
verwendet das ist das schlechteste logo das ist das schlechteste logo was ich seit langem
gesehen habe easy os das sieht wirklich mies aus im grunde fast alles mit fast allen systemen machen
es gibt ein das richtig da sind manche systeme einfach sehr sehr eingeschränkt aber das ist
dann auch so gewollt und das heißt das hier ist eher so eine richtlinie und ja die systeme
kommen natürlich mit einem gewissen umfang das heißt wie ist die installation erst mal wie es
zum beispiel auch die erste nutzer erfahrung und dementsprechend habe ich die mal versucht hier
einzuordnen so da das jetzt alles sehr sehr nun ja unübersichtlich ist habe ich mal versucht hier
ein paar kategorien irgendwie erinnert mich die stimme von ihm an irgendwer mir fällt gerade nicht
ein an wen und dieses thema da so ein kleines bisschen einzuteilen wir sehen massive effekte
linken seite sind eher die systeme die anfänger verwenden auf der rechten seite sind eher die
systeme die die profis verwenden und das ist ok da muss ich mal kurz gucken ob was ok also zeigt
mal her anfänger und heute wir sind anfänger feels bad man ok also ja gebe ich ihm gebe ich
ihm voll und ganz recht hier ubuntu elementary mint ganz klar anfänger system man jaro auch
ja man jaro auch das ist wirklich ein super einsteiger system wenn man artstellungs haben
will kann ich nur empfehlen moin kosta ubuntu lubuntu peppermint kenne ich nicht kubuntu kubuntu
was auch immer ob zu so geht hör mal auf ja aber da das würde ich auch würde ich so unterschreiben
wie das ja für alte geräte da gab es früher noch pupi linux und so was für alte geräte ja stimmt
würde ich auch so sagen it sehr kali vor allem ja klar für die big brain fraktion hier hinten
gendt für alle für alle die gerne die drei stunden kompilieren bis in den mail anhang
öffnen können wobei wer öffnet heutzutage mail anhänge für alle die komplett gerne selbst
bauen von crux habe ich noch nie was gehört das logo sieht aber auch echt naja gut anhand des
logos kamer des projektes nicht bewerten als den richtigen erstes artlin und wollt linux
ja dann hast du hier die ganzen security anonymität nicht security die anonymitätsgeschichten
dass ja das was was snowden sogar mal empfohlen hat er glaube tails cubes das ist dieses wo
alles wo alles in extra xen vms läuft hunigs habe ich noch nie gehört knobbix live cdr auch
und dann noch vieles dazwischen gaming steam os special interest ja easy os pop os pop os
haben sogar mal ausprobiert scientific linux scientific linux gibt glaube ich nicht mehr
klappt es wurde eingestellt aber die einteilung kann ich kann ich nur sagen ja finde ich gut
gemacht würde ich auch so machen so oder so ähnlich exzellent irgendwie gewertet also wenn
man jetzt ein profisystem nutzt dann heißt das nicht unbedingt dass man mehr machen kann ja
matze fragt eine gute frage warum man jaro als anfänger es basiert auch auf art und artis
jeder stimmt allerdings ist viel komplizierter einzurichten als man jaro und man jaro hat noch
ein paar andere sachen sie haben beispielsweise eigene repos dazwischen dass man nicht mehr die
komplett also man jaro pakete sind manchmal so zwei wochen verzögert oder so also man kriegt
nicht die volle bleeding edge ladung wie in art sondern schon dann die bisschen ausgeblutete
ladung in man jaro am man jaro ist auch ein system was wirklich für einsteiger was man
verwenden kann wenn man ein bisschen interessiert ist ich finde man kann es nicht auf das gleiche
level stellen wie jetzt den linux mint oder so den linux mint ist ein system was wirklich fast jeder
noob der nicht komplett zwei linke hände verbinden kann verwenden kann man jaro nicht allein schon die
man jaro installation ist ein bisschen hakelig da sieht man da haben keine leute dran gesessen die
jetzt wirklich viel wert auf auf eine noob verständliche installation gemacht haben aber
man jaro ist im vergleich zu einem komplett arch linux von hand installieren immer noch viel
viel angenehmer man könnte man könnte man jaro eher so eher so hier so dazwischen irgendwie
anorten zwischen profi und anfänger wobei man halt sagen muss generell die unterscheid zwischen
anfänger und profi ist halt die frage es ist ja nicht so als könnte man mit einem profisystem
jetzt so viel mehr machen als wir mit einem anfängersystem ich verwende man jaro hauptsächlich
weil es in arch linux ist aber ein paar sachen einfacher sind ja dadurch wird es auch anfänger
freundlicher aber letztendlich verdiene ich tagtäglich mein geld unter anderem damit dass
ich linux verwende also gerade das ist ja das was man quasi unter pro bezeichnet jemand der mit
in der gewissen sache sein geld verdient und man kann auch als pro in anführungen strichen
ein anfängerbetriebssystem nehmen und damit sein geld verdienen kein problem als mit einem
anfängersystem im endeffekt kann man auch mit einem anfängersystem wirklich alles tun wie
ist genau das sagt er ja auch hat er recht und ja teilweise sind einfach die profisystem viel
umständlicher teilweise sind sie einfacher eben zu bedienen aber es ist eher so die nutzererfahrung
wie viel wissen braucht man wie stark muss man sich durch irgendwelche anleitungen wühlen und
es funktioniert auch wirklich gut wie gesagt ich verwende auf der arbeit seit jahren nur noch man
jaro überhaupt kein problem funktioniert wunderbar hat drei notebook generationen überlebt mit dem
terminal machen so habe ich das ungefähr mal eingeteilt so also noch mal ganz kurz zu den
anfängersystemen wir sehen oben links das steam os und das ist wirklich ein system was nur zum
zocken geeignet ist das ist quasi der big picture modus von steam mehr ist das system nicht und das
läuft als linux gaben os einem rechner wo man dann zum beispiel zocken kann ich empfehle dieses
system tatsächlich nicht unbedingt weil es also klar komplett sinnlos kann man sehr sehr viel und
sehr sehr gut zocken aber wenn man gamer ist dann wird man natürlich auch maus und tastatur zum
beispiel hauptsächlich verwenden wollen zum zocken und ich persönlich mag einfach den big
picture modus nicht aber das hat hier nicht wirklich was damit zu tun aber man kann auch
zum beispiel keine epic games spiele zocken oder eben andere spiele zum spielen ist linux nach wie
fair natürlich nicht ja naja wirklich nur die steam spiele also zum zocken vielleicht ein
anderes linux nehmen das funktioniert dann eventuell wenn man spielen will bei der way
einfach in windows nehmen fertig und man hat keine probleme mehr auf einem anderen linux
kann man genauso steam installieren wie auch auf es sei denn man möchte super talks card spielen
aber vielleicht noch interessanter links unten die anfängersysteme ich empfehle meistens man
jaro oder linux mint für wirklich anfänger allerdings sind die beiden relativ linux mint
linux mint würde ich anfängern auch empfehlen ja man jaro nicht man jaro eigentlich eigentlich
nicht also wenn wirklich jemand sagt hey ich verwende hauptsächlich windows mache aber jetzt
nicht so viele sachen die windows und die software erfordern so die basic sachen von surfen bis
ein bisschen bisschen youtube videos gucken und so was dem würde ich ganz klar sagen probiere
mal linux mint aus und schau wie es dir gefällt ja aber und das muss man auch allen anfängern
immer sagen denkt nicht dass man das gleich verwenden kann wie windows es hat doch viele
unterschiede video gemacht was denkst du zu chrome os eigentlich nix noch genauer drauf
eingehen man hat ja aber natürlich auch noch andere systeme wie elementary zorin os und
zorin hat mir gar nicht gefallen linux us der namen ist wirklich furchtbar dann lubuntu und
mx linux genauso wie magaya und opensuse kubuntu linux lite und kubuntu sind eigentlich alles
anfängersystem alles klar da kann man einfach mal klingt wie irgendwie schwedisch oder so
system googeln und dann kann man da schon ein paar bilder sehen und vielleicht ist das eine
bild ansprechender als das andere und dementsprechend kann man sich hier für ein system entscheiden
es gibt hier die kautz gute frage fragt wenn es um linux neben windows nutzen geht lieber
einfach eine vm für linux oder dual boot es kommt darauf an was du machen willst unter
linux in der regel würde ich sagen fangen mit einer vm an und guck ob es dir reicht weil
eine vm und eine linux vm unter windows zu betreiben ist deutlich angenehmer als dual boot
wenn man halt auch windows sachen braucht aber wenn du zugriff auf deine hardware brauchst dann
ist halt mit vm nicht wirklich ja ich würde mit einer vm anfangen hast auch den vorteil wenn
du was kaputt machst ist nicht schlimm als sondern es gibt nur alternativen zu und genau
das stimmt da hat er recht da hat er recht was euch besser gefällt ist definitiv die bessere wahl die
systeme die ich jetzt hier nicht eingeordnet habe die in der mitte liegen das sind systeme die so
allrounder sind das heißt jetzt nicht dass die anfänger systeme nicht auch allrounder sind aber
die systeme in der mitte sind vielleicht nicht ganz Leute jetzt war mal big brain frage welche
der distributionen die hier gezeigt werden ist die älteste welches ist hier die älteste
in den distributionen
xd kennt sich aus leute ihr habt chat also man muss sagen die vielen subscriber haben geholfen
der iq ist so hoch dass die erste richtige antwort slackware ist korrekt die anfänger
systeme zumindest meiner erfahrung nach also der chat ist wirklich heute wieder außer sich
vor gehirnleistung ne slackware unten eine kategorie für alte geräte alte geräte bedeutet wir haben
zum beispiel eins ist also einen wirklichen pc der jetzt zehn jahre oder 15 jahre alt ist
pentium 2 pentium 2 ich habe mich hat mal vor fünf jahren oder so mal auf dem pentium 2 400
lief es schon länger her wobei doch fünf jahre könnte hinkommen vor fünf jahren habe ich
auf dem pentium 2 400 aus spaß an der freude der pupi linux installiert das ging erstaunlich
gut dort läuft vielleicht nicht die stärkste hardware drauf trotzdem möchte man diesen
pc vielleicht nicht wegschmeißen sondern irgendwas damit machen und dazu gibt es dann
eben die drei systeme lubuntu mx linux und antix das sind wirklich systeme die für ältere
geräte optimiert sind und dementsprechend auch nicht so wie ressourcen also ich habe
immer pupi linux verwendet für alte geräte so schön aussehen ja oben habe ich eine kategorie
aufgemacht ich wusste leider keinen besseren namen die habe ich jetzt mal special interest
genannt die sind tatsächlich für sehr spezielle bedürfnisse also zum beispiel bedrock kombiniert
features von acht linux mit debian zum beispiel und noch ein paar andere dazu scientific linux
ist wirklich für science ausgelegt red hat scientific linux ist nicht wirklich für science
ausgelegt scientific linux ist ein red hat klon beziehungsweise cento s red hat scientific
cento s also cento s und scientific linux sind quasi red hat red hat nachbauten wenn
man keine red hat lizenz lizenzen kaufen will treuung und easy os ist zum feature ausprobieren
gedacht also nicht einfach aber einfach neue features ausprobieren deswegen der name easy
os pop os ist für entwickler gedacht aber trotzdem kann man natürlich mit all diesen
systemen auch pop os hat mir überhaupt nicht gefallen da war nix von dem in der aktuellen
version dabei was ich zum entwickeln gebraucht hätte außer visual studio code pop os hat
mir nur gefallen an jaro linux machen könnte so dann haben wir in der mitte den großen blog
life system anonymität und direkt runter it security also pen testing und forensik für
pen testing und forensik gibt es drei system im endeffekt parrot os kali linux und black
arch basiert auf arch linux kali basiert auf debian und parrot os erfüllt gleichzeitig
noch ein paar anonymitätsfragen die naja von tails auch erfüllt werden von cubes os
erfüllt werden und von hunix erfüllt werden wobei es habe ich noch nie ausprobiert noch
nie gehört andern weg geht cubes und hunix sind allerdings schon halbe profisystem mit
diesen wirklich gar nicht so einfach richtig aufzusetzen zu benutzen ja cubes ist eher
so ein experiment würde ich sagen weil alles in xen 4 m läuft habe ich auch schon ein
tutorial gemacht tels hingegen nimmt den ansatz dass es ein life system ist ja life systeme
sind tatsächlich man startet sie von der cd oder dem usb stick cd den pc hoch man macht
was man machen möchte man fährt ihn runter und der pc hat sich absolut gar nichts gemerkt
also es gibt quasi kein festplatten speichern bei life system das ist sehr gut für security
oder für anonymität um genau zu sein weswegen tels diesen ansatz hier geht cd in 2020 geht
diesen ansatz ansatz auch um eben hier noch einen also es ist eigentlich auch ein richtiges
system aber knoppix wird normalerweise dazu verwendet um sachen wieder herzustellen das
heißt wenn man irgendwie
derjenige der mir den pokies abgeschenkt hat hieß auch morpheus ich entdecke da zusammen
hänge systemverlust hatte oder sowas dann kann man da super guten knoppix nehmen das
ding ist allerdings life systeme werden auch mit allen anderen linux system eigentlich
mitgeliefert das heißt man kann jedes linux erstmal von der cd bzw dem usb stick starten
und einmal ausprobieren aber man hat normalerweise noch die funktion das system zu unterstützen
tels zum beispiel hat diese funktion gar nicht also man kann tels nur auf dem usb stick
installieren in anführungsstrichen man kann nichts speichern das ist aber auch wirklich
der sinn von tels sozusagen sieht man sogar schon im logo ja am ganz rechts sehen wir
da noch ein paar profis systeme die sind auf profis ausgelegt also wirklich für leute
die sich ihr linux so anpassen wollen wie sie das gerade brauchen und dementsprechend
sind sie auch nicht ganz so einfach das heißt linux from scratch das also kurz lfs genannt
das ist tatsächlich man man baut sich seine eigene linux distribution zusammen gen2 ist
auch wirklich ein sehr komplex gen2 ist für die für die leute die eine halbe stunde die
gerne eine halbe stunde kompilieren bevor sie mail mail anhang öffnen können benutze
eigentlich ist auch ein system was bei der installation nicht ganz das einfachste system
ist also die würde ich tatsächlich nur raten wenn man wirklich schon mit linux gearbeitet
hat also nicht als erstes them als erstes bitte eins aus der linken hälfte hier wählen
ja und dementsprechend kann man jetzt hier eigentlich schon recht gut rauslesen welche
systeme ganz gut geeignet sind welche vielleicht nicht mehr ganz so gut geeignet sind noch
ein kleiner weiterer hinweis hier es gibt bei linux einzelne systeme die krasse krasse
animation nun ja erstmal quasi eltern systeme sind also die erstmal sozusagen als knoppings
war knoppings nicht mal ein debian bild für andere systeme dienen und hier ein ganz großes
beispiel ist debian das ist ein system aus dem haben sich so viele weitere systeme entwickelt
dass es der aber ubuntu zählt schon fast als ein eigenes system obwohl es eigentlich auf
debian basiert und ja auf ubuntu basieren dann lubuntu kubuntu kubuntu kali linux beziehungsweise
kali linux basiert auch auf debian da gibt es zwei varianten und so weiter und so fort
das sind sozusagen die ursprünge ok die sich da wirklich raus kristallisiert haben aber
das nur so mal am rande jetzt ist natürlich noch eine weitere große frage im raum und
zwar ja rolling releases das ist quasi als er sagt wo ist mac os irgendwo hier rechts
vom monitor fix releases das ist quasi das release modell von linux distribution jetzt
will das wissen markierten systeme hier die haben das rolling release das ist nicht zwangsläufig
besser es ist nur eine alternative art und weise das bedeutet erst mal ganz kurz fix
release bedeutet sowie bei windows man hat ein windows 8 windows 9 windows 10 windows
11 windows 12 windows 13 14 15 16 man hat ein windows 16 die dann große updates sind
sozusagen und über diese großen updates ändert sich natürlich einiges das heißt man muss
sein system aber auch immer mal wieder wirklich groß updaten oder im zweifelsfall sogar neu
installieren das ist das was quasi ein fix release modell beschreibt ok bei rolling releases
gibt es das nicht rolling releases haben archlinux ist quasi der berühmteste vertreter und alle
die oder die meist von archlinux abstammen haben eigentlich ein rolling release und das
bedeutet wirklich software die veröffentlicht wird kommt relativ schnell auch als patch für
den nutzer dann ja das geht auch relativ schnell kaputt das muss einem klar sein deswegen mag
ich mit mag ich das bei manjaro manjaro hat noch mal so zwischen repos dass man nicht die
komplette kacke abkriegt die da am dampfen ist oder wie sagen sie sagen sie ganz gerne immer
auf englisch shit hits the fan das ist so eine unglaublich dumme rede wendung bei way auf das
system jetzt gerade in diesem moment ein update für zum beispiel eine eine programmiersprache
rauskommt die ich häufig benutze nehmen wir jetzt einfach mal peifen wenn es da die neue version
rauskommt dann habe ich die eigentlich innerhalb von wenigen tagen schon auf meinem rechner während
auf fix release modellen da kann es eine ganz schöne weile dauern bis ich dann auch wirklich
was habe klar natürlich die patches die wirklich wichtig sind die kommen dann relativ schnell also
sowas wie schwachstellen oder security issues die werden dann trotzdem relativ schnell gepatcht
aber große neue version die etwas kaputt machen könnten die werden erst bei dem nächsten großen
release des systems mitgegeben also zum beispiel hat alle zwei jahre ein sehr sehr großes neues
system und ich habe alle zwei lts nur ein kleineres release sozusagen aber alle zwei jahre gibt es
wirklich ein fettes release und wobei das bei ubuntu eigentlich eigentlich gar nicht so wirklich
nicht so hundertprozentig stimmt meiner an sich nach weil die versuchen eigentlich gerade in den
lts releases nichts großartig neues rein zu machen weil sie das die nächsten vier jahre
supporten müssen also die lts releases sind meistens nur das was die letzten ein zwei releases
gemacht haben ein bisschen und ein bisschen neuere updates also in lts releases machen die meistens
keine großartigen experimente sozusagen alles dabei und da sind dann eben auch die großen
neuen updates dabei was natürlich für mich bedeutet ich muss dann auch da quasi mein system
fast neu installieren wobei ich manche sachen natürlich übernehmen kann aber bei arch gibt
es das nicht man hat einfach arch linux man hat nicht irgendwie arch linux 12 oder 13 oder sowas
das gibt es einfach nicht man hat einfach arch und die software auf arch installiert sich einfach
nach und nach selbst und ja ich weiß manche sprechen das arg aus manche sprechen es heißt
arch aber ich sag ja ich glaube es heißt ich bin mir relativ sicher dass es offiziell tatsächlich
arch heißt dazu weil ist so die urfeld ok das ist so quasi das grobe was man hier wissen muss jetzt
ist die frage möchte man das also im endeffekt rolling release kann dazu führen dass das system
kaputt geht rolling release auf dem desktop ist das beste wenn man wenn man wenn man sachen macht
drauf also wenn man sachen programmiert oder halt neue software version haben will ich ich hatte
früher halt auch so diese ganze geschichte von wegen ubuntu und sonst was auf dem server ist das
eine gute geschichte da willst du kein rolling release aber auf dem desktop bin ich mittlerweile
ansicht rolling release beste schon von vielen gehört die sagen rolling release auf keinen fall
in einer umgebung die wirklich funktionieren muss also wenn man drauf angewiesen weil eben
kaputt gehen könnte ich persönlich trotz nutze trotzdem arch linux weil ja ist halt einfach
meiner desktop ist ja auch nicht so wichtig der kann ruhig kaputt gehen da passiert ja nichts der
besten systeme weil ich auch wirklich sehr gut customisieren kann es ist allerdings auch nicht
ganz kostet nicht richtig wobei wir zum letzten punkt kommen welche systeme würde ich vielleicht
am ehesten empfehlen für anfänger würde ich wie schon gesagt mind linux mind oder ja auch
empfehlen ich empfehle anfänger auch immer linux mit themen kann man eigentlich alles machen hier
kommt es nur darauf an möchte man jetzt ein rolling release haben oder möchte man das eigentlich
immer für nicht für absolute kacknubs linux mind hatten rolling release linux mind hat keins das
ist wirklich geschmackssache hier was man da eigentlich verwenden möchte dann gibt es
natürlich noch sehr sehr viele andere systeme die würde ich aber alle tatsächlich also ich
persönlich für mich das ist jetzt nicht das was ihr machen müsst das ist nur mein persönlicher
geschmack jetzt hier gerade ok diese slide und wenn euch jetzt sagen wir mal ein kali linux oder
ein ubuntu viel mehr fasziniert dann nehmt das absolut das ist dann komplett eure geschmackssache
und die könnt ihr dann durchaus auch nehmen für anonymität würde ich immer ein tails empfehlen
es geht nichts über tails in den meisten oder eigentlich nie geht irgendwas darüber cubes ist
ein super system genauso wie hoonix aber trotzdem wenn ihr wirklich komplett anonym sein wollt dann
braucht ihr halt einfach ist so ja und wenn ihr wirklich eine herausforderung haben wollt das heißt
wenn ihr wirklich komplett recht quasi euer zu hause einrichten wollt auf eurem pc dann kann ich
euch wie gesagt auch man in mind kein terminal frau crash fluffy naja für die meisten sachen nicht
aber man muss sich man muss sich bei dem wenn man wirklich mal linux ausprobieren will da muss
man sich mit dem mit dem terminal arrangieren also über kurz oder lang wird man die ein oder
anderen sachen im terminal machen müssen und man sollte man mit linux anfängt auch prinzipiell
dazu bereit sein was im terminal zu machen und sich ein bisschen damit zu beschäftigen weil
viele sachen unter linux gehen nur im terminal oder geht am besten im terminal und es ist ja nicht
so wie windows wo wo das terminal abgrund tiefe abgrund tiefer rotz ist sondern das terminal
programm als auch die shell unter linux ist halt einfach viel viel besser als irgend so ein windows
terminal mit mit mit mit batch ja wobei das nicht ganz einfach ist aber trotzdem eben noch so weit
dass man wenn man es mal eingerichtet hat wirklich sehr sehr komfortabel alles machen kann ja und
das ist so mein fazit hier dazu ich bin gespannt was ihr dazu schreibt schreibt mir gerne welche
system ja finde ich ein gutes video pass deckt sich zu 90 prozent mit dem mit meinen erfahrungen was
ich auch sagen würde aber kann er da auch unter unterschiedlicher meinung was macht er dann
sonst noch für videos das war jetzt wirklich kein kein schlechtes kein schlechtes video 100 ab
aber das ist cool dass man mit solchen videos tatsächlich 100 100.000 abos kriegen kann nicht
nicht übel musste erst mal hinkriegen mein das ist jetzt jetzt ist jetzt nicht so das thema was
jetzt die leute die kls gucken anspricht auch wie soll die worst minigame in selda ist ein bisschen
lang gerade gut die views sind nicht so hoch aber es ist halt einfach auch durch sehr sehr breit was
er hier macht hier kommt irgendwas zum pass decken dann kommt irgendwelche algoritmus und
daten strukturen hier kommt linux distribution vergleich halt sehr breit und da hast du halt klar
dass jetzt sache mal algoritm und dann zu irgendwelche grafen ist das nicht so viel
interessiert wie zum beispiel linux vergleich du könntest mein gameplay video zu meinem neuen
spiel anschauen klar hau rein schick her ich glaube dass das ein bisschen so eine nische ist
wo es in deutschland nicht viele gute channels gibt in der richtung und die videos die wir
bisher von ihm gesehen haben sind auch wirklich kein blödsinn also da kannst du dich nicht
beschweren in pyson tutorials ok strings unreal engine java script
cute gui benutzt du verschiedene vms ja warum was willst du wissen linux upload einsteiger
könnte eigentlich auch mal ein video machen zum thema linux um umstieg einstieg
ich habe es ja schon immer mal ein paar mal angesprochen in ein paar videos aber
ich habe nie ein eigenes video zugemacht
er hat auch auf die hacker doko reagiert ich glaube das haben wir uns schon zusammen
angeguckt ok moment kommt ja kommt jetzt ok der trailer zum neuen spiel von luke aus
mit chat das muss man sich jetzt angucken auf geht's
huge voice effect was sehe ich da es sind zwei blödsinn
zwei quadrate die sich das ist ein bisschen was wie warms warms in echtzeit oder sowas
du solltest das umbenennen ist das ernsthaft announcement solltest das umbenennen im bett
bettel royal wenn es oben in bettel royal und machs auf steam kree an die green light
gibt es ja nicht mehr bettel royal und dann auf auf steam early access excellent ist auf
steam ok das wollen wir jetzt noch angucken ok also wir können uns den neuen half life
den neuen half life 1 weltrekord any percent speedrun angucken der geht 25 minuten ungefähr
alternativ hätten wir noch ein paar andere sachen das ist glaube ich nicht so interessant
was interessiert mich in respiratory pyro erst mit minus 10 look ist eigentlich ziemlich
fein die wir gucken uns die schwersten super nintendo spiele an da bisschen bisschen bisschen
retro zeug für mich ja ich brauche mal ein bisschen bisschen bisschen oldschool zeug
ich muss ich muss muss man uns angucken jetzt bis bisschen oldschool so monka old woop woop
old leute wir haben so viele subs im chat wir müssen wir brauchen einmal eine runde
woop old spam woop old gut dann gucken wir das jetzt ey die waren auch schwer ich muss
aber sagen ich war damals auch hochgradig unfähig deswegen kam mir viele spiele so
schwer vor ich habe jetzt ja die comaten conquer red alert kampagne gespielt gestern
und ich habe mich so schwer getan bei ursprünglichen also bei den levels im original weil das mein
erstes echtzeit strategie spiel war und jetzt war das easy as fuck jetzt war das total easy
zum größten teil nur damals ja nicht ganz nicht ganz nur hoch abonniert acht monate
exzellent dankeschön poggers luco er kein problem wenns wenns neues update gibt sag
bescheid oh das war schwer das ist das dritte donkey kong country das war wirklich schwer
welches ist am start huge bits dankeschön für ja kein problem konnte ich mal wenigstens
jemand reden der es gebrauchen kann donkey kong country generell fand ich die donkey
kong country spiel auch super nintendo ziemlich schwer aber das dreier war echt heftig ja und
diese ganzen shooter diese ganzen wie nennt sich da diese kategorien auch mal so shoot'em
up mäßig die waren auch unsinnig schwer die star wars games die haben wir haben wir
sogar richtig gut gefallen auf dem super nintendo habe ich sogar habe ich sogar fast alle durchgespielt
damals und geob bettel totes warum kenne ich warum kenne ich fast jedes game beim ersten
bild schon monka es bettel totes das ist auch unsinnig schwer
all seriousness if there's a game you think that deserves to be on here leave a comment
below and explain why one other thing no broken unplayable castlevania das ging eigentlich
oh gott kontra 3 war das kontra 3 ich glaube kontra 3 das ist das was in deutschland auch
wieder zensiert war laut genug eigentlich
ja ich erinnere mich dunkel ich hatte das game nicht ich hatte das
game nicht aber ein kollege von mir aus der schule hatte das ich hatte den dritten teil
nicht aber ich kann ja was sind das für einspieler dazwischen
ja die waren alle alles am ziemlich schwer die ersten paar
ich finde immer geil wie die amis richter aussprechen richter der richter
die ganze castlevania spiele die ersten waren echt schwierig
3 Monate dankeschön excellent subscription huge und jetzt kommt das gem train leute das
gem train ist am start auf gehts
das gem train fährt
oh das ja diese dinger waren ultra schwierig
ok das meine ich gar nicht aber es gab noch mehr solcher spiele die waren alles am brutalst
schwer
well
Except pure speed and quick reflexes the biggest problem here though is that if you die you start with nothing
You're some sorry slow-ass ship again. So you have no chance to get past this part. You might as well just start over
It's usually beneficial to have checkpoints
But in this case it almost works against the game the two token power-ups you get just barely give you enough speed to get past
This part and that's if you're lucky
Earthworm Jim 2. Yeah, as if the first earthworm Jim wasn't hard enough the
Lieblings Corona Emoat. Ne, mein Lieblings Corona Emoat ist das hier. Corona. Beste
Hat mir nie gefallen
Earthworm Jim waren nie Games die mir gefallen haben. Weiß auch nicht. Das war nicht meins
Wahrscheinlich als so abgedrehte Grafikstil hatte
Nicht nie gespielt
Viele Disney Spiele waren auch echt Pains Jam auf dem Super Nintendo
Der hat nur eine Eidle animation oder
Was do you read on video yes, high quality, whatever
Sieh sehrilik boy
Sieht sehrlusion sehr fair aus
xt
gewesen, aber echt saumäßig schwer. Ich glaube das habe ich nie mal ansatzweise durchgespielt.
Ihr seht ja, beste 4 zu 3 Format, exzellent.
Battle Toads ist unnützschwer, auch die NES Variante.
Ich fand die Spiele nicht mal gut, die waren einfach nur schwer und sonst nix.
Hab ich nicht gespielt, keine Ahnung. Ja RTX Spiegelung, guckt hier. RTX on.
König der Löwen war auch schwer auf dem NES, hat er ja auch gerade erzählt. Viele der Disney Games waren unsinnig schwer und hatten sehr merkwürdiges Movement.
Kennt ihr mal noch dieses komische Schlümpfe Game auf dem Super Nintendo? Das war auch komplett für'n Arsch. Das war Steuerung auf Doom.
Okay, ja das war schwer, der braucht schon Checkpoints.
Oder habe ich das gespielt und das andere nicht? Ach keine Ahnung, ich weiß nicht mehr genau.
Das war nie so meine Art von Spielen, das war für zwischendurch ganz gut.
Eins meiner Lieblingsspieler auf dem Super Nintendo neben den offensichtlichen Sachen wie Link to the Past, Mario World und so war das erste Mega Man X, das habe ich gern gespielt damals.
Und ich fand's auch voll schwer, obwohl's gar nicht so schwer war.
Kommt einfach noch ein Gegner reingeflogen.
Oh ja, das war auch ultra frustrierend.
Das war ein richtiges Stealth-Game im Endeffekt, du musstest immer zwei Pixel vorgehen und in die Richtung der Gegner spammen, dann gucken ob was passiert, dann wieder zwei, also eigentlich hat's mir auch nicht gefallen.
War ich doch, doch, äh, ich glaub man musste das mehrfach sogar durchspielen.
Ich meine die Steuerung allein schon, generell hatten viele Super Nintendo Spiele echt kacke Steuerung.
Ja, die fand ich auch cool, die fand ich nice.
Kann mich da noch dran erinnern, die fand ich gar nicht so schwer, also, ich bin mir auch nicht sicher welche, ich glaub ich hab's ja alle gespielt, aber ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, kann auch sein, dass es nicht alle waren.
Die Spiele hatten Helden-Auswahl, man konnte am Anfang der Levels teilweise die Helden auswählen und in der Regel waren die Helden, die schießen konnten, viel besser als die Helden, die nahe an die Gegner ran mussten.
Da gab's so'n Mode 7 Level, wo du mit dem Raumschiff rumgeflogen bist und eigentlich kaum was erkannt hast, vielleicht hab ich das nicht gespielt, sondern die einfacheren.
Ich glaub das hab ich nicht gespielt, hab ich nicht gespielt, keine Ahnung, war das nicht eines der letzten Games, die für den Super Nintendo erschienen sind, da war doch irgendwas, ich erinnere mich dunkel, wahrscheinlich kamen sie auch gar nicht in Deutschland raus.
P.A.M. ja.
P.A.M.
Was, was hätte man da jetzt machen sollen?
30 wieder an Gegner spawnen, exzellent.
Ok Leute, wollten wir uns jetzt den aktuellen Half-Life 1 Weltrekord noch angucken?
Auf was hatten wir uns geeinigt?
Chat?
Von dem Typ haben wir doch schon mal was geguckt, oder?
Der kommt mir irgendwie bekannt vor.
Ich glaub das letzte, 27 Minuten.
WTF, he is playing another game while speedrunning.
Ok, nice.
Ok, bin ich mal gespannt.
Der spielt wirklich irgendwie Star Wars oder sonst was noch nebenbei WTF?
Ich will nicht wissen wie viele Milliarden Stunden der wieder in dem Game hat, warte
mal ganz kurz.
Der hat alle Stunden, da sind keine mehr übrig.
Ich find's immer geil, wenn die dann irgendwie sagen Hello Gordon und der Typ schon irgendwie
3 Kilometer weiter.
It's good to see you Gordon, ich bin schon 20 Kilometer weiter gesprungen.
Oh, wie es ruckelt, das ist teilweise so precise wie du da das Zeug springen musst.
Huge, huge animations von 1998.
See, he continued moving, he didn't stop.
Man konnte doch die NPCs irgendwie schieben, he?
Der spielt wirklich ein anderes Game während der Half Life Speedrun, WTF?
No challenge, no challenge.
Ist das Jedi Knight oder was ist das?
Weird, weird flex, weird flex, das ist Dual Speedrun, ich wollte auch gerade sagen Griego
neues Meta, man speedrun einfach zwei Spiele gleichzeitig.
Und nebenbei Weltrekorde in eine machen, eigentlich ist das richtig big brain, warum sollte man
nur ein Weltrekord machen, wenn man zwei Weltrekorde gleichzeitig machen kann?
Eigentlich ist das richtig next level.
Einfach double Worldrekord, die übertreibst die Leute, gerade rechtzeitig da um den Knopf
zu spammen.
Ah, exakt dieser Pixel muss es sein.
Ich finde es so geil, wie er ein zweites Game nebenbei spielt, wenn Speedrun von einem
Game zu langweilig wird.
Winklino ist echt so, stellt euch vor, ihr habt den Half Life 1 Weltrekord, ihr habt
jahrelang geübt für das Spiel und dann kommt er da her und spielt zwei Spiele nebenbei.
Und easy as fuck Worldrekord, man muss es halber sagen, es ist jetzt nicht ganz so extrem
wie es aussieht, in dieser Zeit, er muss ja in Half Life nichts machen, er muss einfach
nur das Timing abpassen, wann er wieder ins Game muss, aber trotzdem geil, trotzdem geil.
Als nächstes kommt wahrscheinlich noch ein Minecraft Survival Speedrun dabei als drittes
Game, weil da musst du noch weniger machen.
I have to wait on them I guess, oh if you have the right angle I think you can run up here.
Vor allem, wie der in seinem Kopf auch zwischen den beiden Games umschalten kann, so nach
dem Motto, so wir machen gerade mal Half Life Speedrun, so und jetzt spielen wir ein Star
Wars Game, so easy, keine Frage.
Vor allem mit dem Half Life Sounds im Hintergrund hört es sich irgendwie verkehrt an.
So weiter gehts, Half Life Speedrun, ja der schaut gerade im anderen Game wie er 7 Sekunden
schneller sein kann, während er den Half Life World Record macht, das ist seriös.
Wow, man kann da raus, wusste ich gar nicht, dass das geht, das ist was Neues, oder?
Leute, ich bilde mir einen im letzten Half Life Speedrun, wo wir geguckt haben, war das
noch nicht drinne.
Was heißt, in diesem Universum ist eigentlich die Katastrophe in Black Mesa nie passiert,
weil Gordon hat nie das Sample in den Strahl geschoben.
Das ist neu, Revers Player EU, hab ich so auch noch nicht gesehen, der überspringt quasi
den ganzen Weg von diesem Reaktor Raum bis hier oben hin, ja, ich glaub der hat auch,
ne ne ne, das Brecheisen hat er nicht übersprungen, das Brecheisen ist hier erst, aber das Movement
ist extrem flüssig, ne, das Movement ist so krass flüssig, der bleibt nirgendswo dran
hängen und hat permanent Bunny Hop Speed, hier unten siehst du ja den Speed, das ist
so flüssig, wie der sich bewegt, Half Life ist eigentlich ein relativ langes Game, also
so First Person Shooter mäßig, Half Life würde ich mal behaupten eines der längsten
Single Player Kampagnen, kannst du ne ganze Weile spielen, oder halt in 25 Minuten durchspielen.
Der hat jetzt einfach mal das, der hat einfach mal komplettes Level geskippt gerade, WTF,
the fuck, der ist durch die erste Held, naja nicht durch die erste Held, durch erste Drittel
vom Spiel ist der gleich durch, genau die fragen, und was hast du in der Mittagspause gemacht,
ach ich hab zweimal Half Life durchgespielt, diese Bunny Hop Speed Geschichte geht nur,
wenn du, wenn die Kamera, wenn die Kamera movet, es gibt dazu ein richtig schönes Tutorial
Video, also dass diese Bunny Hop Speed Geschichte, dass du den Speed halten kannst, musst du
in einem gewissen Winkel zur Wand gucken oder irgendwie sowas, ich krieg's nicht mal zusammen,
aber das gehört dazu, dass er schneller laufen kann.
Letztendlich geht das ganze übrigens auch nur, weil das Quake Engine ist, das ist das
Bunny Hopping, das Bunny Hopping in der Quake Engine.
Das erste Drittel vom Game ist fertig, nach vier Minuten.
Da kann man übrigens gar nicht reinkloppt normalerweise, da kann man erst rein nachdem
man hier einmal durch ist, krass, da fuck alter, jetzt boostet er sich, er ist auf der Leiter
gelandet da unten, hab das gesehen, er ist auf der Leiter gelandet, dass er keinen Damage
nimmt, jetzt gibt's noch mal einen Granatenboost, das Game ist, glaube ich, relativ schwierig
bis zum letzten, bis so das letzte Viertel anbricht, dann hat man, dann hat man nahezu
unendlich Leben, aber bis dahin ist es ziemlich, ziemlich durchoptimiert, ich find's eigentlich
cool, dass es diesen, diesen Unlimited-Leben-Klitsch erst so im letzten Viertel gibt, dass bis dahin
muss man das Game noch richtig spielen, okay, richtig spielen ist jetzt übertrieben gesagt,
also durchwetzen, aber ey, das Movement ist so flüssig, da steckt viel Übung dahinter,
ich hab gedacht, er wechselt jetzt aufs andere Spiel rüber, während er Aufzug fährt, das
wär's jetzt gewesen, das hätt ich damals auch gerne gemacht, immer dieses rumgerenne
durch diesen Tentakelraum, der sieht total entspannt aus, ja anscheinend, das ist easy
mode für ihn, wahrscheinlich hat er auch 4000 Stunden oder so schon in Half-Life, was gibt
denn das jetzt, ah, dass er da drüber kommt, alles klar, excellent, ui, und ins Wasser,
dass er keinen Damage nimmt, aber das Movement ist so übertrieben flüssig, obwohl du in Half-Life
an jeder Ecke hängen bleiben kannst, der hat Glück, dass ihn die Headcrab nicht killt,
der hat doch nicht, ich hab vergessen, dass er die Xen-Levels noch spielen muss, also
der ist doch noch nicht ein Drittel durch gewesen am Anfang, wo ich gesagt hab, jetzt
ist er ungefähr ein Drittel durch, also das erste Drittel ist quasi, bis die Soldaten
auftauchen, dann das zweite Drittel ist, bis man in die Alien-Welt kommt, das letzte Drittel
ist quasi die Alien-Welt, der ist schneller als die NPCs spawnen hier richtig, very nice
war, wieder einfach mal den Boss gemacht hat, easy as fuck nebenbei, oh, man kann doppelt
aufladen, what, what, what the fuck, was war das, what is happening, was passiert, oh,
finally, okay, alles klar, Ray, er klitscht, den Klitsch, mehr oder weniger, den kannte
ich damals auch schon 1998, ich hab das damals so gemacht, ich hab mich mit diesen Minen,
die man an die Wand hängen kann, kennt ihr noch diese Minen mit dem blauen Laserstrahl,
die man an die Wand hängen kann in Half-Life, da haben wir uns auch über die Wand drüber
geklitscht, dass wir das Level nicht spielen mussten, also quasi auch schon Speedrun-Stats,
und on Rail haben wir auch oft gespielt ohne Rail, die Dinger da meine ich, okay, das ist
mir so nicht bewusst, dass das wirklich ist, normalerweise sollst du hier ja mit so einer
Minibahn rumfahren, so exakt von ihm, jetzt kommt die Rakete,
also bis dahin spielst du normalerweise so 6 Stunden oder so, 6-7 Stunden, 8 HP, da darf
nicht auf die Kleise kommen, für mich wird das alles nach Good Pace aussehen, oh, Reload,
2 KS, 8 HP und 14 Schild, Kappa, er Saved ja auch alle paar Meter, ich glaube das hat
zwei Gründe, erstens, dass er sich natürlich nicht so weit resetet wird, wenn er stirbt,
und zweitens, schaltet Saving irgendwelche Sachen aus, ich glaube manche Sachen spawnen
nicht, manche Sachen haben keine Hit Detection und manche Sachen lösen nicht aus, wenn man
Saved im richtigen Moment, wenn er im falschen Moment Saved ist auch RIP, ja, alles vorbei,
das haben sie in Black Mesa übrigens rausgenommen diesen Part hier, einfach mal durch die Wand
kurz aufladen, das Game möchte übrigens nicht, dass du hier draußen bist, weil neben dir
gerade eine Rakete startet, in dem Game stehst du hinter dem Fenster im Raum und kannst normalerweise
nicht raus, den Portal Speed Trial, ja klar, Pater oh Herrli, 4 Monate, Dankeschön, Exzellent
Subscription, Big Brain, warum muss man eigentlich storytechnisch die Rakete hochjagen, wegen
irgendeinem Satellit, ich hab's nie richtig gecheckt, ist die Half Life 1 Speedrun Community
groß, ich weiß nicht, man konnte einfach mal gucken wie aktiv neue Runs Submitted werden,
genau das ist der Satellit um das Portal zu schließen, irgendwie sowas, richtig, Half
Life Lore, Kekwe, oh er ist gestorben, und jetzt kommt die Szene, ich hab's euch ja schon
oft erzählt, die werden wir jetzt wahrscheinlich gar nicht sehen, wo ich als Kind übelst Schiss
vor hatte, wenn der Fisch aus dem Wasser kommt, hast du Alex gespielt, nee noch nicht, ich
hadere noch mit mir eine 3D Brille zu kaufen, eine VR Brille für ein Spiel, hier, da hatte
ich übelst Schiss vor, wo ich klein war, vor dem Fisch der da aus diesem trüben Wasser
kommt, aber man kann ihn auch einfach skippen, easy, WTF, das ist normalerweise unter Strom,
aber kann man nicht durch, easy, so, Halbzeit, so, halbzeit, halbzeit, halbzeit, halbzeit,
das war doch nur für das Schlüssel im Nvo.
Die gar nicht, man muss die gar nicht kíllen.
Ich dachte immer man muss diese Assassin Typen kíllen dass das weiter geht, was hältst
du von VALORANT, ich hab es eigentlich nicht gespielt, ich kenn's nur aus Streams, ich
Ich finde gut, dass es mehr CS ist als Overwatch.
Ich guck's gerne an.
Das wird mitgerechnet, das Save und Load.
Aber der ist auch echt krass in dem Game.
Und wenn man sich das Movement anguckt, wie flüssig der das hinkriegt, ist Wahnsinn.
Was ich in der Half-Life Story ja nie so richtig kapiert habe ist,
warum bringen sie Gordon Freeman an der Stelle nicht einfach um
und werfen ihn lieber in eine Schrottpresse.
Das ist so Low-Brain von den Gegnern.
Weißt du, du hast einen, der 100 Leute von dir gekillt hat.
Du nimmst ihn gefangen und anstatt ihn einfach zu killen,
wirfst du ihn in eine Schrottpresse und lässt ihn unbeaufsichtigt in der Schrottpresse liegen.
Exzellent, genau so. Genauso muss man es machen.
Übrigens, man kann die Schrottpresse fahren, weil, das sieht das Spiel eigentlich nicht vor,
die Schrottpresse ist im Spiel eine Bahn.
Boah, der ist echt gut. Aber gut, eigentlich umsonst den Weltrekord.
Boah, er ist gestorben.
Alter, was, was geht jetzt ab?
Okay, alles klar. Ja, alles klar, alles klar. Ich blick voll durch, was passiert gerade.
Was passiert überhaupt?
Ja, ist schon klar, dass es ein Damage Boost ist, aber wie flüssig er das macht, ist Wahnsinn.
What? Das geht?
Okay, alles klar. Guck, wenn man jetzt speichert, lösen die Minen nicht aus.
Ah ja.
Die Gegner müssten sich auch nur denken, war da was?
Der ist bestimmt guter CS-Surfer, ja, glaube ich auch.
Ah ja, alles klar.
Oh, das war nervig, wenn du die Wissenschaftler hier retten musst.
Moment, man konnte Sorum doch gar nicht durch, warum konnte der Sorum durch?
Easy.
Auf, mach hin.
Ich habe immer auf den Wissenschaftler gewartet, dass er mit raus kann.
Keine Speedrun Stats.
Wow.
Ah, exzellent.
Was mache ich jetzt?
Alles klar.
Schuss kann ausgeladen werden, das ist gut.
Easy, und direkt im Rohr landen.
Okay, wir fliegen mal kurz über...
Was?
Okay, alles klar.
Alles klar.
Du machst das anders.
So, gleich gibt es den, äh, demnächst kommt der Unlimited-Leben-Klitsch.
Würde man sagen so zwei, drei, oder zwei Minuten oder so.
Wie die nicht treffen?
Okay, ein bisschen Glück gehört auch dabei.
Jetzt, jetzt kommt der Unlimited-Leben-Klitsch.
Also seht ihr, es gibt die Möglichkeit, man kann sich hier einklemmen in der Tür.
Und es geht aber wohl irgendwie nur so an dieser Tür.
Und jetzt overflowet das Game total die Lebensenergie.
Guckt, seht ihr das hier unten?
Und jetzt hat man mehr oder weniger fast nahezu unendlich Leben.
Jetzt kann er auch noch direkt Damage boosten, wie verrückt.
Warum sollte man das aufschießen? Man kann das einfach von Hand machen.
Normalerweise sollte man auf dieses Artillerieding und dann auf so einer Map einstellen, wo das aufgeschossen wird.
Aber man macht das einfach selbst.
Kein Problem, kein Problem. Easy.
Okay, so ungefähr zwei Drittel vom Game sind durch.
Aber wisst ihr, was ich an dem Speedrun cool finde?
Mehr oder weniger, es gibt, es gibt einiges, es gibt schon einiges.
Aber dass er mehr oder weniger das Spiel spielt, vom Ablauf her, wie es so sein muss.
Dass es kein komplettes Out of Bounds-Klitschen ist oder so.
Sondern dass das Spiel einfach nur gespielt wird.
Und das sind eigentlich die besten Speedruns.
Und wo man halt auch wirklich sieht, der Typ kann es, der hat es halt richtig drauf.
Oh, ich dachte immer, man muss den Panzer killen, dass es weitergeht.
Oh, anscheinend nicht, anscheinend nicht.
Ja, Skyrim Speedruns sind unter anderem total lame.
Und auch die normalen Doom Eternal Speedruns sind lame.
Aber die Ultra Nightmare Speedruns sind cool.
Was?
Okay, nice.
Witcher 3 Speedrun habe ich, weiß ich nicht, ob ich da schon mal eingeguckt habe.
Hat er gerade durch die Wand irgendeinen gelasert?
Jetzt switcht er erst mal auf das andere Game wieder gleich.
Ja, die Portal Speedruns finde ich tatsächlich so gut.
Die sind beim ersten Mal cool, aber danach werden sie langweilig.
Wobei ich mir einen Half-Life Speedrun durchaus vier, fünf Mal angucken kann.
Im Jahr ist kein Problem.
Gibt es dieses Jahr Games Down Quick? Keine Ahnung. Guck ich auch nicht mehr in letzter Zeit.
Funktioniert das alles auch bei Black Mesa? Nein.
Ein paar Sachen funktionieren noch, aber das ganze Movement ist anders.
Black Mesa hat eine neuere Version von der Source Engine.
Also mal ganz davon abgesehen, das hier ist ja noch nicht mal die Half-Life 2 Source Engine.
Das ist ja Gold Source, die Half-Life 1 Engine unten drunter.
Und bei den neueren Source-Versionen funktioniert auch das Movement ein bisschen anders als bei Release-Versionen.
Nee, nee. Ein paar Sachen funktionieren bestimmt noch, aber das meiste kannst du in Black Mesa nicht machen.
Zumal Xen komplett anders in Black Mesa ist.
Moment. Das geht? Man muss den Fight nicht machen. Das geht?
Moment.
Ich dachte man muss den Fight machen, dass man in den Teleporter springen kann.
Hier ist normalerweise quasi der End-Fight auf der Erde. Das ist quasi eine Art Boss-Fight hier. Die gibt's gar nicht.
Okay. Ja, alles klar. Na dann. Nicht denken wissen, Neo. Genau.
Ah, yes. Excellent.
Ist der Fight nicht bei Blue Shift? Bei Blue Shift kommst du hier kurz vorbei.
Bei Blue Shift darfst du nicht in das Portal hüpfen, weil dann stirbst du. Bei Blue Shift musst du dann irgendwo abbiegen zwischendurch.
Warum kenne ich eigentlich noch den Half-Life Level auswendig?
Weil Boomer.
Half-Life 1 ist mittlerweile älter als die YouTube Deutschland Community. True. 0W. Ja. Ist so.
Half-Life 1 ist 22 Jahre alt. Kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen.
Es ruckelt ein bisschen.
Don't look at chat. Das ist immer eine gute Idee, wenn man sich konzentrieren will.
I might not get sub 27 here, but follow my Twitch. Maxam1337 on Twitch.tv.
Okay. There we go. You got it, guys.
Und wie slaughter das Game down?
Command. Ach, das ist erlaubt. Okay, das hätte ich nicht gedacht.
Genau. Das habe ich damals auch schon rausgekriegt gehabt, als ich es gespielt habe.
Dass man den Boden hier aufsprengen kann ohne den Gegner.
Das habe ich damals auch schon rausgekriegt.
Was ein Move. Na gut, das ist ein bisschen hängen geblieben, aber trotzdem immer noch extrem gut.
Das ist Weltrekord.
Ist übrigens gleich fertig. Normalerweise bräuchte man jetzt noch ungefähr eine Stunde.
Er macht es in einer Minute. Easy.
I should stop talking. Every time I say something like that, I fail. Commentators curse.
Got it. Oh mein Gott. Don't fail, Maxim. Easy Boss Fight jetzt.
Übrigens eigentlich muss man dem Gegner in den Kopf schießen.
Aber anscheinend kann man eben auch in Bobbles schießen, dass das ins Gehirn geht.
Also quasi vom Hintern ins Gehirn, das ist egal.
Easy win.
27 13. What is this time, dude?
Easy World Record nebenbei noch ein anderes Game gespielt.
Heftig, echt heftig.
Also da sieht man richtigen Skill in einem Game.
GG Eats. Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
What the fuck? Nicht so laut.
Um wie viel hat er den Weltrekord geschragen? Guck mal mal Speedrun Half Life.
Ist das die richtige Kategorie?
Max, ja, das muss es sein. Er hat den Speedrun geschlagen.
Na gut, das war vor neun Tagen. Also den hier hat er geschlagen.
Oha, guckt mal hier.
Richtig, 27 13. 40 Sekunden, so 45 Sekunden schneller. 50, 50, 50 Sekunden, genau.
50 Sekunden.
Das ist heftig. 50 Sekunden schneller. Das ist ja Massive.
Und da ist auch noch ein bisschen Luft nach oben.
Der vor neun Tagen ärgert sich bestimmt, ja bestimmt.
Heftig.
MonkaS.
Ja Leute, ich muss jetzt was essen. Ich hab Hunger wie Sau.
Die restlichen Videos heben wir uns für das nächste Mal auf. Vor allem das hier.
Ah.
Danach Warzone. Ja, aber nicht im Stream.
Ich muss jetzt erstmal was essen. Ich hab Hunger.
Gibt es irgendjemanden, den wir hosten können, der on ist?
Der es gebrauchen könnte.
Keine, dem ich folge.
Okay Leute, sehr schön, dass wieder so viele dabei waren. Beim Aufwachen.
Vielleicht sehen wir uns morgen wieder. Oder heute Abend, oder so. Man weiß ja nicht. Mal gucken.
Ich bin ja in letzter Zeit relativ, relativ, ich wollte euch noch was, ich wollte euch noch was fragen. Hab ich ganz vergessen.
Und zwar, was ich euch gestern schon noch fragen wollte ist, ich bin ja in letzter Zeit relativ oft am Start.
Also guck mal, wenn man jetzt hier bei mir mal schaut auf Twitch, dann sieht man ja, wenn man auf Videos geht.
Nein Max, ich will mich nicht selbst hören.
Wenn man auf Videos geht, sieht man ja das.
Videos.
Da sieht man ja, ich bin relativ viel on in letzter Zeit.
Drei Stunden, 21 Stunden, 2 Tage, 5 Tage, 6 Tage, vor 6 Tagen, vor 7 Tagen, vor 8 Tagen.
Also ich bin ja gefühlt jeden zweiten oder dritten Tag on.
Ich hab kein Schedule, nein hab ich nicht.
Aber, ich wollte euch nämlich was fragen.
Es ist ja in letzter Zeit so, seitdem ich so oft streame, dass ich nicht mehr in jedem Stream vorher einen Plan hab, was ich genau machen will.
So, jetzt ist die Frage, was ist euch lieber?
Soll ich nur streamen, wenn ich mir vorher was überlegt hab, was wir machen können?
Oder soll ich weiter streamen, wie jetzt einfach, wenn es mir danach ist?
Weil jetzt würde ich mal sagen, früher bin ich halt immer on gekommen, wenn ich genau was spezielles vor hätte.
Und jetzt komm ich halt auch die Hälfte der Zeit on, ohne dass ich großartig was vor hab.
Du entwickelst doch immer was tolles raus, das ist schön, wenn das so funktioniert, ja.
Weiter wird's.
Excellent.
Dann machen wir das weiter so.
Ich guck dir auch zu, wenn du auf AliExpress komische Gabel kaufst.
Ja, das müssen wir übrigens demnächst mal wieder machen.
Ich muss tatsächlich mal wieder AliExpress was bestellen.
Und meine AliExpress-Lieferung, die wir vor zwei Monaten oder so bestellt haben, ist immer noch nicht da.
Aber das liegt, glaube ich, an Corona.
Wir können diesmal auch bei Banggood was bestellen.
Ja, bester Shop-Name.
Banggood.
Okay, dann machen wir weiter so wie bisher.
Also, bis denn, bis morgen oder so, mal schauen.
Macht's gut, ich muss jetzt erstmal aufs Klon was essen.
Bis denn, CU!